et besoin de retourner à des choses plus
essentielles en fait est vraiment de
sentir qu'on n'est pas forcément un
poids pour la planète
il ya une idée derrière il ya une
philosophie aussi qu'on a vu la serre
les plantes poussent le fait de vivre
avec les plantes comme ça vraiment
commune comme un machine un organisme
pour fait partie de cet organisme
on a eu vraiment l'impression de se
construire en même temps qu'on
reconstruisait cette maison en faisant
toutes ces rencontres et je pense que
ces genres de projets qui se fait pas
tout seul dans son coin on est dans un
truc vraiment de coopération de partage
de partage
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le zéro derma pigmentosum c'est une
hypersensibilité aux rayons ultraviolets
en fait c'est une maladie génétique qui
est transmise par les deux parents n'ont
plus de parents sont porteurs sains de
la maladie ce qui transmed qui se
transmettent en fait alors à leurs
enfants des enfants ne peuvent pas
s'exposer au soleil
acial comment on pourrait résumer une
journée type de votre vie ce qu'il faut
savoir c'est que il faut pas qu'ils
aient un millimètre de pau qui soit
exposé importe ses gants ses vêtements
on leur met leur masque avec la visière
qui leur permet de regarder à
l'extérieur
une fois qu'ils y sont ma fille je veux
pas qu'elle ait une vie où il reste tout
le temps à la maison c'est pas une vie
tu auras la vie comme tout le monde et
ça je le ferai tout pour que ça soit le
cas
beaucoup plus
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue sur arte france
pour deux heures d'émission nous
décrypterons comme chaque soir du lundi
au jeudi
l'essentiel de l'information avec nos
invités en plateau et nos reporters sur
le terrain
voici les grands titres de l'actualité
de ce lundi 2 mars le niveau de risque
lié au corona virus au sein de l'union
européenne passe dans la catégorie
modéré à élevé la barre des 50 décès a
été dépassé en italie en france emmanuel
macron bouleverse son agenda pensons
consacrée selon l'elysée à la gestion
l'épidémie quelque 130 contaminé sur le
territoire de personnes originaires de
l'oise ont perdu la vie 3 au total dans
l'hexagone des manifestations attendues
demain en france l'intersyndicale
appelle à des mobilisations dans tout le
pays
elle entend protester contre le recours
aux 49 3 les deux motions de censure
déposée par l'opposition contre le
gouvernement seront débattus demain à
l'assemblée et la conférence de
financements et fo vient d'annoncer
qu'il a quitté élections législatives en
israël aujourd'hui une nouvelle
tentative à former le gouvernement benny
gantz rival du premier
ministre benyamin nétanyahou a voté à
rosh haayin les deux hommes boucle ainsi
la troisième campagne électorale en
moins d'un an
les résultats sont attendus dans la
soirée l'échappée erdogan rencontrera
vladimir poutine jeudi à moscou le
président turc dit espérer parvenir avec
son homologue russe un cessez-le-feu en
syrie les migrants continuent d'affluer
vers la grèce depuis que la turquie est
ouvert sa frontière à nyala merkel qui
juge inacceptable qu ankara fasse
pression sur je cite le dos des réfugiés
aux etats-unis le supérieur tous des ou
super mardi en français c'est pour
demain avec le vote simultanée de 14
états dont la californie
un scrutin qui s'annonce décisive dans
la course à la primaire démocrate joe
biden se présente en pleine confiance en
ayant remporté la primaire de caroline
du sud et se place en rival de bernie
sanders ce dernier comptant deux
victoires sur quatre
[Musique]
le risque de niveau de risque est lié
aux coronavirus dans l'union européenne
entre dont désormais dans la catégorie
modéré à élevé
c'est ce qu'a annoncé la présidente de
la commission européenne ursula von der
leyen en france emmanuel macron
bouleverse son agenda pour se consacrer
selon l'elysée à la gestion l'épidémie
134 de corona virus ont été recensés sur
le territoire de nouveaux décès annoncés
des personnes originaires de l'oise
département le plus touché par le virus
au total trois morts dans l'hexagone 12
régions françaises sont touchées
françois c'est ce qui évite écoles
fermées et arrêté interdisant tout
rassemblement collectif jusqu'au 14 mars
dans le morbihan
la préfecture a décidé de prendre des
mesures cinq mille sept cents élèves
seront ainsi privés de cours pour le
moment mon arrêté
c'est donc quatorze jours ci du 1er au
14 en fait à l'instar de ce qui a été
fait dans l'oise comme dans haute savoie
il n'y a pas de jauge en fait les
rassemblements dans un lieu fermé sont
interdit les rassemblements de masse
sont interdits de fer que nous pussions
éviter la programme propagation rapide
du virus établissements scolaires
également fermés dans l'oise à
crépy-en-valois l'un des foyers de
propagation
les habitants prennent leurs précautions
sans pour autant s'alarmer chamakh est
plus costaud
non
je suis zen non on verra par la suite
mais pour l'instant ça va
en plus on se lavait les mains plus
souvent aussi bon là je vais jouer au
sort de la pharmacie j'ai réussi à avoir
un petit flacon l'afjel bon ben on m'a
conseillé de plus tôt dans m bon ben je
fais plutôt remettre un peu vu voilà sur
la main et puis si je rentre à la maison
en espérant que tout se passe bien
à paris certains événements sont d'ores
et déjà annulés
c'est le cas du salon du livre qui
devait se dérouler du 23 mars le musée
du louvre lui est resté fermé après le
vote d'un nouveau droit de retrait par
le personnel de quoi décevoir les
touristes est-ce que je pense que c'est
une bonne raison pour fermer le musée
n'en est vraiment pas à lui préféré être
à l'intérieur ça permettrait à paris ont
fait un long voyage pour venir ici je ne
suis pas sûr que la fermeture du muscle
et arrêt place propagation
les transports en commun ne sont pour
l'instant pas impactés des restrictions
sont envisagées en cas de passage au
stade 3 de l'épidémie le seuil d'alerté
maximum
mais aucun arrêt du trafic vous avez
compris que ces plans de continuité
d'activité
il vise à trouver le meilleur équilibre
entre le fait de constater qu'on a un
virus qui peut circuler
à ce stade trois plus largement dans la
population qu'il faut évidemment
ralentir la progression de ce virus et
en même temps il s'agit pas d'arrêter le
pays
il faut que chaque français devienne un
acteur de ce combat contre les
coronavirus a appelé de son côté edouard
philippe lors d'une visite d'un centre
hospitalier de bordeaux pour le premier
ministre se laver les mains toutes les
heures et d'ailleurs probablement la
meilleure façon de le faire
et pour en parler nous sommes avec
olivier youinou infirmier anesthésiste à
l'hôpital henri mondor à créteil membres
du syndicat sud-santé ap-hp bonsoir
olivier oui nous merci d'être avec nous
191 cas ce soir que disent ces chiffres
selon vous 191 cas en france qu'on va
vraisemblablement passer à l'épidémie
stat 3 c'est à dire que alors qu'on
seriez encore les foyers n'est qu'on
pouvait distinguer les malades porteurs
qui contaminait aujourd'hui on va avoir
une
une épidémie sur l'ensemble du
territoire et on n'aura plus ces
contingents là on aura un virus qui va
circuler et qui va contaminer de plus en
plus de personnes ça c'est une envie de
réussir à maîtriser ses salons je ne
crois pas je crois pas est ce qu'on doit
s'en inquiéter traitement non c'est
toute la question c'est dire voilà faut
pas que ces mots fasse peur il a émis
pandémie mais est-ce qu'on doit s'en
inquiéter selon professionnels que vous
êtes alors moi le professionnel constate
qu on est déjà inquiet et il ya une peur
une psychose qui s'installe dans le pays
autour de ce coronavirus je crois qu'il
faut relativiser les choses
que ce soit sur la gravité de
l'infection elle-même et sur sa
mortalité par ce que il ya des
et il ya des maladies qui sont bien plus
mortel que ce que l'on va connaître là à
travers coronavirus donc relativiser
avoir un message plus apaisant peut-être
on a l'impression gens discutaient
encore en venant ici que chacun devient
un expert en santé parce que on va sur
les réseaux on regarde sur internet on
se fait sa propre idée et on devient un
diagnostiqueur un médecin en soi donc il
faut arrêter tout ça pour revenir à
quelque chose de plus sérieux que les
professionnels les infectiologues les
virologues nous dit ce qu'il en est
exactement de ce qui est risqué des
populations à risque
et puis ce qui vraisemblablement vont
passer à travers peut être contaminée
peut être porteur mais qui n'auront pas
les mal assis là
le niveau grave de la maladie donc
essayer d'apaiser un peu le climat ça me
semble nécessaire aujourd'hui vous dit à
juste titre voilà on affronte euros vous
dis pas ça comme ça mais ça veut dire la
même chose on nie tout et n'importe quoi
chacun s'improvise experts vous avez
certainement pas tord mais enfin c'est
peut-être aussi parce qu'on ne sait pas
grand chose
j'ai eu des grands professeurs ici qui
nous ont mis bas en fait on on sait rien
alors on ne sait pas pourquoi les
enfants sont pas à temps je ne sais pas
si avec la chaleur ça va partir vous
voyez il ya tous ces aspects peut-être
qu'ils nourrissent l'anxiété
on sait par contre que aujourd'hui la
mortalité n'est pas non plus celle que
l'on peut connaître par ailleurs il ya
moins de morts aujourd'hui par
coronavirus qui a par la grippe
saisonnière
alors restera ça il ya moins de morts
aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui parce qu'on nous dit
l'inversé de la crise de la grippe
saisonnière c'est 8000 morts huit à dix
mille morts par an sur le territoire
on n'en est pas là encore aujourd'hui la
l'épidémie va s'installer on va voir ce
qu'il en est mais les mesures de
protection sont les mêmes que pour la
grippe
quelles sont les populations c'est
peut-être ça que les spécialistes
doivent nous dire qui doit faire
attention est ce que lorsque l'on est
fragilisé par une infection pulmonaire
déjà c'est là qu'on est
et que l'on recense les cas de mortalité
il faut qu'ils nous disent aussi tous
ces cas où les patients sont infectées
par le virus et passe à travers deux des
fois même des symptômes ou qui se passe
dans coronavirus comme ils passent dans
une dans une grippe et s'en sortent très
bien
je crois qu'il faut essayer de donner
ces messages là à la population avant
d'en arriver à une psychose où chacun on
le voit déjà dans le métro pointe du
doigt l'asiatique en lui disant non je
veux pas discuter avec toi ou est très
suspicieux de qui à la moindre toux dans
l'est la proximité proche
ça veut dire que en clair ces mesures
parce que c'est tout simplement des
mesures qui nous viennent du
gouvernement qu'on est supposé tout se
respecter quand on vient bon ben
maintenant sur la france aussi un vous
me direz mais quand on vient d'une zone
à risque saga pour l'asie voilà des pays
d'asie du sud est l'italie on doit
garder ses enfants à la maison ils ne
peuvent plus aller au collège au lycée
c'est pareil pour les salariés ils sont
confinés chez eux c'est peut-être ça qui
nourrit est ce qu elles sont excessives
selon vous ces mesures je sais pas si
elles sont excessives en tout cas on y
revient pour ne citer que le directeur
général de l'assistance publique il
avait pris ces mesures là il avait isolé
et demander à un confinement au domicile
50 de ses agents il se pose la question
aujourd'hui est notamment pour prendre
en charge une éventuelle épidémie de
rappeler c
ces agents parce qu'ils sont
asymptomatiques et que s'ils portent le
masque
ça peut peut-être le faire il essaie de
raisonner aujourd'hui ce qu'il faut un
grand bénéfice risque et se dira
peut-être que des infirmiers des aides
soignants même contaminé avec un masque
seront plus utiles pour prendre en
charge les patients à l'hôpital que de
rester chez eux confiné en attendant
les résultats du test pour vous le
confinement c'est pas forcément le
prendre le bon le problème par la bonne
par le bon bout par d'autres
ça a déjà été choisi le confinement a
été déjà choisi comme mesure aujourd'hui
on y revient à moi c'est la question que
je pose
il faut pas que ce soit pour des raisons
strictement économique que l'on revient
sur des positions que l'on a choisi a
priori en toute conscience en ayant pris
informations auprès des professionnels
des infectiologues et les virologues de
notre institution notamment
qu'est ce qui fait qu'aujourd'hui on
reviendrait sur cette décision l'agencé
rien peut-être que l'épidémie n'est pas
ce qu'elle
ou ce que l'on prétendait peut-être
qu'elle est moins grave que ce que l'on
dit encore j'en sais rien mais on a
besoin de cet éclairage là moi je ne
suis pas vous l'aviez dit en
introduction je suis pas un virologue ni
un infectiologue xian infirmiers
anesthésistes et j'ai pas cette
connaissance là
spécifique que ces spécialistes là nous
disent exactement ce qu'il en est
quelles sont les populations à risque
pour des développements graves de la
maladie et quelles sont les populations
très certainement plus nombreuses pour
lesquels juste de la prévention simples
permettraient de passer le stade vous
dit vous n'avez pas cette expertise mais
vous en avez en revanche à une autre
dont vous pouvez vous nous parler celle
du terrain du concret on a entendu
plusieurs médecins nous lire oui le
souci c'est que s'il ya une vraie
épidémie en tout cas si les gens sont de
plus en plus nombreux à être malade
le souci serait peut-être de ne pas être
avoir la capacité d'être en charge
notamment réanimation dans les cas les
plus graves
on l'a vu ça avec la fermeture de la
réanimation de creil et le rapatriement
des patients
vers les réanimations de l'assistance
publique il faut savoir aujourd'hui que
l'assistance publique a dit à 1000 lits
de fermer faute de personnel parce qu'on
n'arrive plus à embaucher à l'assistance
publique parce qu'on a contraint
financièrement notre établissement et
que aujourd'hui on est plus attractif
dont les professionnels ne viennent plus
travailler chez nous et on affirme
émilie ça pose une problématique et vous
comprenez bien qui va au delà de
l'épidémie coronavirus c'est n'importe
quelle épidémie qui arrivera n importe
quelle situation exceptionnelle qui
arriverait aujourd'hui sur le territoire
en région parisienne pour ce qui est de
l'assistance publique
on ne sait pas si on est en mesure de
prendre en charge les patients comme ils
devraient l'être en qualité et en
sécurité parce qu'on a plus les moyens
et pour vous justement cette épidémie va
changer quelque chose dans votre combat
sera une peut-être une prise de
conscience pour espérer de cela en tous
les cas on espère beaucoup du changement
de ministre comme quoi une sextape
pourrait peut-être changer la situation
on espère aussi que
face à une épidémie de cet ordre là on
prenne conscience pas simplement les
professionnels pas simplement les
dirigeants pas simplement le
gouvernement mais la population de la
situation dans lesquelles l hôpital
aujourd'hui pour y remédier le plus
rapidement possible ça fait plus d'un an
que les professionnels sont dans des
mouvements sociaux réclamant non pas
pour eux mais réclamant des effectifs
pour prendre en soin correctement et
l'ouverture de lits quand la population
en a besoin et c'est le cas aujourd'hui
il est grand temps que le ministre parce
que la précédente ne l'a pas fait il est
grand temps que le ministre actuel
reçoivent les professionnels en
mouvement social depuis plus d'un an et
discute avec eux sur des négociations
au vu des revendications portées je
crois que ce serait un message fort à
donner aujourd'hui aux hospitaliers sur
lesquelles on va encore compter sur leur
engagement leur dévouement leur vocation
ça suffit qu à un moment donné vous
savez on fait des heures supplémentaires
à n'en plus finir
on a mille deux cents jours un million
deux cent mille jours qui sont déposés
sur ce qu'on appelle des comptes épargne
temps et pour lesquels on n'a pas été
payé pas et qu'on n'a pas pu récupérer
et on nous dit encore aujourd'hui qu'on
va jouer sur les heures supplémentaires
de ses agents là pour reprendre en
charge l'épidémie ça suffit ça suffit
merci beaucoup olivier youinou d'avoir
été avec un infirmier n'est saisi ce
membre également du syndicat sud santé à
l'hôpital henri mondor à créteil merci
merci à vous et on en parle encore de ce
coronavirus premiers foyers en europe
l'italie qui a enregistré près de 500
nouveaux cas en 24 heures la barre des
50 décès a été dépassé ce soir près de
1700 personnes testées positives au
total ailleurs dans le monde deuxième
pays le plus touché après la chine la
corée du sud qui recense près de 615
supplémentaires au total plus de 4300
contamination c.hall séoul qui décide de
porter plainte pour homicide contre les
leaders d'un mouvement religieux qu'elle
accuse de ne pas avoir permis d'empêcher
la propagation de l'épidémie dans le
pays et puis autre est a touché l'iran
la france l'allemagne et le royaume uni
annoncent qu'ils vont fournir un au pays
un soutien matériel et financier
les politiques le recours aux 49 3
relance la contestation sociale en
france l'intersyndicale s'est réunie ce
matin la cgt fo la cfe cgc la fsu et
solidaires ainsi que les organisations
de lycéens et étudiants appellent à
manifester demain partout en france
aujourd'hui plusieurs milliers de
personnes se sont mobilisées comme ici à
paris ou encore à lyon
les manifestants dénoncent ce passage en
force sur la réforme des retraites
écouter le député de la france insoumise
adrien bot et nantes
moi je veux rappeler ce que nous avons
fait à l'assemblée nous n'avons rien
fait d'autre que d'emporter au sein de
l'hémicycle
un mot d'ordre qui est majoritaire dans
le pays qui est l'exigence du retrait de
ce texte
ce projet de loi est illégitime puisque
il ne correspond absolument pas à la
promesse présidentielle d'instauration
d'un système universel il n'y a pas de
système universel
il n'y a pas un euro cotisé offrira les
mêmes droits il y a en l'occurrence une
vaste mesures d'âge qui va faire en
sorte que les français et un niveau de
pension qui va s'affaiblir parce qu'il
sera la seule variable d'ajustement de
l' équilibre financier qu'ils
recherchent donc avec les amendements
c'est ce que nous avons voulu faire je
montre qu'on entende bien que 41 mille
amendements sur un texte aussi important
que celui là c'est très loin d'être de
l'obstruction parlementaire
c'est un 49,3 des tournées et abusif
puisque le 49-3 normalement ne sert pas
à faire taire l'opposition parlementaire
le 49-3 sert à un exécutif qui craint
que sa majorité ne vote pas le texte
un recours aux 49 3 très contesté jusque
dans la majorité présidentielle
sénateurs la république en marge des
bouches-du-rhône michel amiel qui est
ainsi parti dans un communiqué ils
dénoncent une décision qui relève selon
lui du cynisme et de l'incompétence
politique opposition elle a déposé deux
motions de censure contre le
gouvernement le seront débattus demain à
l'assemblée nationale et au combat avec
guillemin rossi
17h26 ce samedi et doit philips avance à
la tribune devant les rangs clairsemés
de l'assemblée nationale à l'issue d'une
nouvelle suspension de séance
il annonce alors ce que l'opposition
redoute depuis plusieurs jours
conformément à l'article 49 alinéa 3 de
la constitution de 1958 et après en
avoir obtenu l'autorisation du conseil
des ministres du 29 février
j'ai décidé d'engager la responsabilité
du gouvernement sur le projet de loi
instituant un système universel de
retraite non pour mettre fin au débat
mais pour mettre fin à cet épisode de
non débat à un parlement privé de sa
fonction éminente de faire la loi et
pour permettre à la suite du processus
législatif de s'engager
une déclaration qui prend les députés
par surprise y compris ceux de la
majorité
selon le quotidien le monde la plupart
des élus et les rues même qu'ils ne se
trouvent pas en séance apprennent la
nouvelle à la radio ou sur leur
smartphone alors que la tension monte
dans le pays en raison de l'épidémie de
coronavirus l'annnonce de l'exécutif a
fait l'effet d'une bombe
certains parlementaires appartenant au
parti présidentiel sont sidérés
c'est une incompréhensible erreur
politique stratégique et institutionnels
deux motions de censure ont été déposés
par l'opposition
la première provient des républicains
l'autre est porté par une alliance entre
insoumis communistes et socialistes
d'émotion qui ont toutefois très peu de
chances d'aboutir
pour être validée et renverser le
gouvernement il faut obtenir une
majorité absolue au sein de l'assemblée
nationale située à 2 189 députés
or malgré les exclusions et autres
départs la majorité présidentielle
dispose toujours de 299 sièges auxquels
il faut rajouter
sauf surprise les 46 députés modem
depuis 1958 c'est la 89e fois qu'un
gouvernement engage sa responsabilité
vient le 49-3 quant aux motions de
censure
elles n'ont quasiment jamais abouti dans
toute l'histoire de la vème république
une seule a été adoptée par l'assemblée
c'était en 1962 contre le gouvernement
de georges pompidou il y a donc presque
60 ans soir sébastien jean sébastien
ferjou merci d'être avec nous en direct
sur rt france attend en vain mot déjà
sur cette contestation qui reprend de
plus belle en france est-ce qu'elle va
servir à quelque chose selon vous elle
va servir à quelque chose en tout cas
pas pour empêcher la procédure du 49-3
ni le fait que
le projet de loi puisse être en première
lecture à l'assemblée nationale a adopté
après la problématique politique reste
entière pour le gouvernement c'est à
dire que ce qui est un peu perturbant
c'est pas leur courant soit au 49 3
votre reportage le rappeler c'est loin
d'être la première fois qu'un
gouvernement recourt à cet article la de
la constitution en revanche c'est le
contexte
et là on voit bien qu'il ya un problème
de calendrier et non seulement bien
point de calendrier mais peut-être moins
de maîtrise de la part du gouvernement
puisque si le gouvernement en gros il ya
les élections municipales le
gouvernement souhaitait avoir fini avant
en tout cas la phase de l'assemblée
nationale avant
le premier tour des municipales ce qui
l'a contraint à s'engager dans une
procession une procédure accélérée et
c'est ce qui lui a fait qu'il ne peut
pas bénéficier de la procédure de temps
de temps programmé parlementaire donc le
gouvernement s'est lui même mis dans la
masse dans la nasse juridique on voit
bien que le sujet peut-être plus que
d'empêcher la reprise du mouvement c'est
d'empêcher ou de mettre un terme aux
débats qui commençait à se faire jour au
sein de sa propre majorité
si les élections municipales il ya
beaucoup de candidats qui sont enfin
deux candidats qui portent les couleurs
de la république en marche sur le
terrain qui se heurte à une forme
d'hostilité de la population et donc
c'est compliqué quand on est candidat
aux municipales à la fois de devoir
défendre nationalement le projet de loi
sur la réforme des retraites tout en se
montrant plus dubitatif dans les faits
pour éviter de suicide électoral
cette stratégie pour vous allez
finalement c'est méline de la part du
gouvernement où elle est totalement
suicidaire voire inconsciente suicidaire
je ne sais pas mais manny non je pense
qu'il ya pléthore allemand parlant je
pense qu'il ya vraiment une forme
d'amateurisme vraiment une femme et je
faisais sur la technique même
parlementaire un manque de maîtrise
quant au sens politique par philippe a
pu faire la preuve dans le passé qui
n'en avaient pas forcément des quantités
industrielles à revendre enfin c'est lui
qui n'a pas vu venir la crise ou en tout
cas ce que les protestations qu'elle ait
généré des 80 km heure sur la taxe
carbone c'était la même chose sur un
certain nombre de choses comme ça je
même sur le congé parental vous savez
quand on est député quand on a reproché
aux députés d'avoir voté contre un
amendement proposant d'allonger le congé
de deuil pour des parents qu aurait
perdu un enfant c'était quand même
remonter à matignon et matignon il n'y a
pas vu de problème je pense que le
calcul politique est assez hasardeuse et
que rien n'est réglé parce que l'enjeu
politique reste le même mais
effectivement c'est quand même une
réforme qui met la majorité du pays
contre le gouvernement les sondages le
disent les français en majorité ne
veulent pas de cette réforme les bulles
et les avocats dans la rue c'est assez
rare on peut se demander comment un
gouvernement espère effectivement gagné
les municipales et peut-être d'autres
élections après en passant en force
comme ça je sais pas si le gouvernement
espère encore gagner les municipales
puisque l'association ce sont des
élections compliquées pour la république
en marche qui a peu d'ancrage peu
d'ancrage
territoriale en revanche il ya un enjeu
politique majeur pour le gouvernement et
pour emmanuel macron en particulier dans
la perspective d'une éventuelle
candidature en 2022 qui de dire regardez
ce que d'autres n'ont pas su faire avant
moi j'ai réussi à le faire et dans un
pays qu'on dit li réformable j'ai réussi
à mener à bien une réforme que beaucoup
avaient voulu entreprendre auparavant à
savoir en soit la réforme des retraites
d'ailleurs et de mettre un terme aux
régimes spéciaux maintenant moi je vois
trois questions politiques qui se pose
pour le gouvernement qui dans ce pays
est capable de dire si cette réforme est
juste ou non et si le système est
produit sera plus juste que le système
précédent parce que c'est une chose de
vouloir marquer des points sur la
réforme mais les gens sont pas non plus
totalement aveugle ils peuvent se poser
des questions sur l'intérêt de la
réforme qui qui seraient passés donc est
ce que cette réforme va être juste 2 2
est-ce que elle garantit mieux que le
système actuel la pérennité du système
de retraite français même chose je suis
pas certain qu'il soit possible d'y
apporter une réponse en état et de 3,7
réforme est-elle maîtrisé et on le voit
aller les études d'impact personne n'est
capable véritablement de faire des
études d'impact donc je trouve ça fait
quand même beaucoup d'inconnues et que
se lancer dans une réforme systémique
à la limite même si on est en faveur
d'une réforme d'un passage à un système
par points se lancer dans une réforme
systémique quand on a une minorité
sociologique dans le pays même sa
légalité et légitimité incontestable à
la majorité en marche
m'enfin y'a pas une adhésion
majeur à sa vision sa vision du monde se
lancer dans une réforme de cette ampleur
là ça me paraît très très casse cou
politiquement et edouard philippe qui
tente de rassurer le nouveau texte est
enrichi de tous les acquis de la
négociation avec les partenaires sociaux
et les amendements déposés par la
majorité
selon lui ce qu'on peut bien le croire
alors que vous le soulignez on a du mal
à connaître les tenants et aboutissants
de cette réforme
je pense qu'il ya des sujets qui sont
quand même paru d'un parce qu'ils
étaient apparus malgré tout pendant les
deux ans de concertation ou alors parce
qu'ils sont portés par les uns ou les
autres soient des députés de la majorité
soit des partenaires sociaux ayant
plutôt envie de travailler avec le
gouvernement pour que cette réforme ne
passe donc le gouvernement fait des
efforts incontestablement il ya des
choses qui ont été inclus ou qui seront
inclus dans le va être soumis justement
au vote par le 49-3 il ya des efforts
qui ont été faits maintenant derrière il
ya quand même le sénat et la majorité
républicaine au sénat ne va pas faire de
cadeau au gouvernement puisque le
président du sénat gérard larcher a
demandé un report de 15 jours en disant
ça n'a pas beaucoup de chance de nous
demander d'examiner le projet de loi
alors qu'on ne sait pas quelles seront
les conclusions de la conférence de
financement donc c'est à la fois très
très défendable sur le sur le fond d'un
point de vue rationnel et il ya aussi
une habileté à le faire de cette manière
là parce que la réalité c'est que
vraisemblablement il n'y aura pas de
compromis trouvé dans la conférence de
fiances de financement merci beaucoup en
tout cas jean sébastien ferjou fondateur
d'attac d'atlantico d'avoir été avec
nous en direct sur rt france est resté
avec nous dans quelques instants nous
reviendrons sur les élections
législatives en israël avec des
électeurs invités à élire leurs députés
pour la troisième fois en onze mois et
puis nous évoquerons l'escaladé de
tensions dans le nord ouest de la syrie
une rencontre est prévue à moscou entre
vladimir poutine et reichert tayyip
erdogan
[Musique]
mais non
non
j'ai fort potentiel programme moi et je
ferai que ce que qu'ils soient tués un
gros boum moon et des viennes humain je
vous emmène découvrir les robots les
plus high tech qui vont bientôt sortir
de leur laboratoire pour rentrer dans
nos maisons
[Musique]
l'ère des robots approche nous avons
l'opportunité de pouvoir changer le
monde
ceux-ci excitant ils vont changer notre
manière de nous divertir d'apprendre le
communiqué en fait et avons changé notre
vie
[Musique]
non
que veut-il dire en japonais qui comme
mourir alors il veut dire qu'il ne sort
pas de chez soi simplement le propre du
phénomène hikikomori c'est que on trouve
des jeunes au japon qui refuse de sortir
de chez eux alors qu'eux ils n'ont pas
de pathologie identifiée dans la
nomenclature psychiatriques aujourd'hui
les quais komori ne sont pas des fadas
de jeux vidéo c'est pas des gens qui
passent tout leur temps dans leur
chambre scotché à l'ordinateur à jouer
aux jeux vidéo et c'est un documentaire
qui permet de comprendre emploi ce
phénomène est vraiment spécifique de la
culture japonaise au japon la pression
scolaire est extrêmement forte
mais les parents s'endettent souvent à
vie pour que leurs enfants fassent des
études et puis vous savez au moment de
la crise d'adolescence un bel quelque
chose qui est remis en question
c'est une super méga crise d'adolescence
considérablement majorait par la
situation économique culturel social
familial qui lie au japon
on a construit
attention attention la tête mais qu'est
ce qui fait que nous allons découvrir le
meilleur de kertch on a construit ça
doit être bon
attention on a construit et le bon tu le
vois oui il est en construction on la
construit avec six mois d'avancé
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
20h30 heure française merci de nous
rejoindre en direct sur rt france une
campagne sale est lamentable c'est en
ces termes que le président israélien a
qualifié la campagne des élections
législatives troisième vote aujourd'hui
en moins d'un an les principaux
adversaires le premier ministre benjamin
netanyahu et benny gantz le dernier vote
n'a pu les départager
et selon les derniers sondages les deux
adversaires seraient encore au coude à
coude
le même scénario que lors des
précédentes élections est donc pressenti
mais nouveauté cette fois ci l'un des
rivaux est inculpé bayemi netanyahu pour
corruption
il appelle au vote malgré le gros
n'avion uc s'est engagé hier avec s'est
rapidement indépendante et la
cisjordanie
on va aller voter
allez voter c'est un jour de fierté
démocratie vous avez un droit que vous
avez exercèrent de la conscience la
question du coronavirus est complètement
son contrôle
aujourd'hui nous avons pris toutes les
précautions nécessaires les gens peuvent
aller voter en toute confiance boris
vian mais je reste plus quelques
décisions des scellés m'ont dit ton
contre les hells et pour en parler nous
sommes en direct de tels avis avec
jacques benillouche journaliste
indépendant bonsoir jacques benillouche
mer
d'être avec nous en direct sur rt france
à ce que vous avez tout d'abord
peut-être des dernières informations dit
que voilà ils seraient au coude à coude
une fois de plus mais ce que vous nous
confirmer ça alors il ya des bruits qui
circulent mais vous savez que le scrutin
sera clos dans une demi heure
et c'est à dire que en fait dès qu'il
n'est clos deux minutes après nous avons
besson base sortie des urnes
donc pour l'instant il n'y a que des
défauts des informations dans certains
cas ce sont des pecs news vous savez
quand un français venu en israël il est
très étonné de la façon dont les
élections se passent par ce que il n'ya
jusqu'à la dernière minute on peut
contacter les
les électeurs les parties sont à
l'entrée des bureaux de vote pour aussi
fait encore la publicité on peut faire
de la publicité un peu partout et donc
on se dit que c'est pas notre façon de
réagir et c'est pour ça que jusqu'au
dernier moment on pense qu'il peut y
avoir des changements et des changements
notables alors pour une petite précision
pour comprendre la situation
nous avons une knesset parlement
monocaméral de 120 députés
il faut 61 députés pour avoir une
majorité
tous les sondages il ya eu à peu près
cinq instituts de sondage qui ont publié
des résultats il ya deux jours met le
pratiquement à égalité
le likoud et benny gantz et donne à la
coalition sortante entre 56 et 57
députés c'est-à-dire loin de la majorité
loin ces quatre députés évidemment alors
cela veut dire que si belge et benjamin
netanyahu n'atteint pas la majorité de
60 voix
il n'a pas de réserves autour de lui et
à mon avis ce sera un échec total et
tout je dirai tout la décision qu'il
attend de ces élections c'est de savoir
s'il va pouvoir continuer à mon avis je
vais utiliser un terme un peu violent
il échoue c'est un homme mort
politiquement parce que le 17 mars il va
passer devant les tribunaux accusé en
tant que accusés pour 10 des
détournements et caetera et caetera et
donc on pense que sa carrière sera
terminée
s'il atteint la majorité est bien
effectivement il sera à nouveau des
pulpes premier ministre et il aura droit
à quatre ans d'immunité pour continuer à
procéder a lancé pour ça que on a un
c'est a vraiment un problème important
et c'est pour ça que je reçois toutes
les quarts d'heure un coup de téléphone
de bibi c'est des enregistrements
évidemment des enregistrements qui nous
demande de voter d'aller voter 2 n'a pas
oublié voté pour penser à voter etc
la situation est grave dit-il alors ce
qu'on peut dire pour l'instant c'est que
paul on a une participation très
importante
c'est surprenant parce qu'on a toujours
dit que au terme des trois élections la
population est lasse on ne veut plus
entendre parler des élections n'ira pas
voter
eh bien on sait qu'il y aura un point de
plus en mars aux élections les deux
dernières élections on a eu 69 68 % de
votants ensuite 69 et aujourd'hui on va
frôler les 70 % des lecteurs c'est
beaucoup alors ça prend ça profite à qui
c'est acquis ce qu'on peut dire c'est
que ça profite d'abord aux partis arabes
je pense que les partis arabes ont
compris qu'ils ont un rôle à jouer et
qu'ils doivent s'intégrer dans la
politique israélienne jusqu'à présent
les arabes sont considérés comme des
pestiférés
les hommes politiques arabes bien sûr
sont considérés comme des pestiférés
tous les partis disent on va pas ce que
ce s'allier avec eux etc
je pense qu'aujourd'hui ils vont avoir
un rôle à jouer
parce que si l'on prévoit qu'ils aient
de pas qui passe de 12 députés à 14 15
députés voire 16
si jamais on a laissé les sondages qui
nous le donne c'est beaucoup c'est très
important c'est plus de 10% de la deux
du nombre de
deux députés donc je pense que le
problème va se poser la question va se
poser du rôle des députés arabes ils
veulent rentrer ils veulent rentrer dans
le spectre politique ils veulent agir et
c'est pour ça qu'il ya un certain nombre
de gens en israël qui dit il est temps
de leur donner la parole
parce que ce ne sont pas tous des des
terroristes vous savez que nous avons le
directeur de la plus grande banque
israélienne est un arabe la banque les
omis nous si vous avez quatre ou cinq
grands hôpitaux en israël qui sont
dirigés par des arabes
vous avez là pratiquement 30% des
médecins qu'ils sont arabes
la plupart des infirmières sont arabes
toutes les caissières de supermarchés
sont arabes
donc c'est à dire c'est celle d'une
population qui est intégrée qui parlent
hébreu qui travaillent et qui ne pensent
pas à mettre des bombes
parce qu'ils vivent alors s'ils vivent
bien ils sont contents ils comparent
leur niveau de vie avec celui de la
cisjordanie leur frère leur part cousins
et ils savent qu'il ya une grande
différence
donc c'est pour ça qu'il est un temps il
est maintenant un temps de penser à
intégrer ca rame dans le contexte
politique israélien et c'est pour ça
qu'il ya une solution qui est envisagée
si natanyahou n'a pas la majorité il est
fort probable que le gouvernement de
benny ganz qui tourne pouvait
instruments la constituer un
gouvernement minoritaire
il limitera en cela le président
l'ancien président xtrac rabin qui en 92
avait eu avait utilisé la même technique
un gouvernement minoritaire
sachant qu'il n'y a pas 60 et une voix
pour le faire tomber puisque
l'opposition je vais vous le dire
la coalition que s'entendre tourne entre
56 et 58 ans elle ne pourra pas le faire
tomber
alors donc ce qu'ils disent on va faire
un gouvernement minoritaire et on
attendra éventuellement de voir d'autres
gens du likoud qui vont enfin penser que
le temps de l'état bien vous est passé
et qu'ils vont pouvoir faire je dirais
un acte entre guillemets de trahison
dont voilà qui peut vous rendez donc
d'angine 2
on saura où bien matam yahoo est en jeu
ont bien natanyahou reste ou encore
quatre en cinq minutes un petit peu
c'est très intéressant ce que vous nous
dites mais effectivement avoir le temps
de poser une ou deux questions quand
même plus rapidement s'il vous plaît sur
quoi sur quels thèmes précis se sont
fait cette campagne et sur quel thème
va-t-elle se jouer selon vous au final
rapidement oui très rapide je vais vous
dire raciste
oui je vais vous dire c'est que je pense
que danse a fait une mauvaise campagne
je le dis honnêtement
parce que quand sa fin d'une campagne de
jacques le masne alors que natanyahou a
fait une campagne très active très
agressive avec des attaques personnelles
avec des faits qui ose avec des vidéos
trompeuses et donc quand tu as fait a
estimé qu'il devait porter être un homme
normal la question donc c'est qu'ils
n'ont pas eu le temps de poser leurs
leur programme on ne connaît pas à
gbagbo
moi j'ai publié un programme de grande
île et il est pas mal mais on n'a pas
discuté personnes en a discuté on ne
dans la campagne électorale c'est une
campagne de personnes
c'est une campagne personnelle l'un
contre l'autre
les attaques de l'important il n'y a pas
de programme c'est à dire pour en fait
on se demande comment les israéliens
peuvent voter
puisqu'ils savent pas quels sont les
programmes de lin et de l'eau il faut se
dire une chose c'est que le d les deux
parties ont un consensus sur le plan
sécuritaire on peut dire que leur
politique sur le plan sécuritaire sont
très voisines
le pays est en guerre donc ils se
soutiennent mais sur le plan économique
il y a des grandes différences sur le
plan économique et un très grand article
du new york times qui est paru hier qui
montre que c'est une fausse idée de dire
qu'israël est très puissant sur le plan
économique
la preuve la preuve à l'heure actuelle
le leur de l'euro qui cote côté c'est
très important pour nous les épaules et
je dirais les les immigrés en israël
l'euro qui cotait 3,65 shekels
aujourd'hui la 3,90 pratiquement donc
l'euro baisse
donc cela veut dire que l'économie c'est
normal parce que l'échappée est non
qu'on n'a pas de gouvernement
ça fait un an qu'on n'a pas de budget et
donc c'est pour ça qu'on commence à
s'inquiéter et celle situation si elle
perdure sur un grand d'une situation
catastrophique pour l'état le
gouvernement on a des problèmes
économiques contrairement à ce qu'on dit
c'est vrai qu'israël est très puissant
c'est vrai qu'il n'a pas de chômage
mais là on commence à sentir l'absence
d'un gouvernement
alors quelle est la solution la solution
très simple
la solution c'est que ayant ou ayant eu
son troisième sa troisième défaite parce
que s'ils n'ont pas eu en trois
élections la majorité pour moi c'est une
défaite
il se retire et il est ce à ce moment là
le likoud au likoud et avec dante
il y aura une majorité sans problème
entre entre le likoud et le parti bleu
blanc s'il n'y a pas des tanneurs entre
les deux cette année qu'on pourrait
avoir une majorité de 70 députés
uniquement parce que c'est seule la
présence de la merci jacques benillouche
on arrive à la fin je suis désolé merci
beaucoup
journaliste indépendant en israël merci
à vous donc alors qu'il sera elle vote
pour la troisième fois pour des
législatives merci à vous
recep tayyip erdogan se rendra en russie
jeudi il rencontrera son homologue russe
veut dire pour qui me pour évoquer
l'escaladé des tensions dans le
nord-ouest de la syrie retour sur les
derniers faits avec mehdi escaffit et
florian lambert nouvelle escalade
militaire entre la turquie et la syrie
deux avions de combat syriens ont été
abattus ce dimanche par les forces
turques à éclipse selon l'agencé de
presse sana
la turquie qui assure vouloir éviter
toute confrontation avec la russie
annonce la poursuite de soufre suivre
dans la région baptisée bouclier de
printemps cette opération déclenchée fin
février a été qualifiée de succès par
ankara vendredi 16 syriens ont été tués
par des bombardements de représailles
menées par l'armée turque dans le nord
ouest du pays
de leur côté la russie et l'otan appelle
au respect des accords de cessez le feu
signé à sotchi
en 2018 le problème surtout c'est qu'il
faut commencer à respecter les
engagements pris et pendant un an et
demi nous avons constaté que pas grand
chose n'a été fait et que l'armée
syrienne a tout à fait le droit de
d'éliminer les terroristes nous
demandons de manière urgente un retour à
l'accord de cessez le feu de 2018 pour
éviter que la situation militaire non
pire encore dans la région et pour
autoriser l'intervention urgente de
l'aide humanitaire pour les personnes
bloquées à l'ibpt le conflit à elibou
aussi de lourdes conséquences sur le
plan humanitaire selon l'onu
les affrontements ont déjà fait des
centaines de milliers de déplacés
les dizaines de milliers de personnes
vivent maintenant dans des abris de
fortune dans les bâtiments que x en
plein air les hardes exposés à la pluie
à la neige dans un froid glacial
rigoureux hiver syriens pour tenter de
trouver une issue à la crise le
président français a pas de la turquie
la russie à établir un cessez le feu
durable dans la région d'idlib
cessez-le-feu que recep tayyip erdogan
espère trouver rapidement de son côté le
kremlin a affirmé que la coopération
avec ankara était d'une grande
importance
une rencontre entre vladimir poutine et
le chef d'état turc doit avoir lieu ce
jeudi à moscou pour en discuter des
conséquences de la situation en syrie
elle est la grèce est confrontée à un
afflux de migrants depuis que la turquie
a ouvert sa frontière pour faire
pression sur les occidentaux
l'agencé européenne de contrôle des
frontières frontex devrait rapidement
lancé une opération de soutien au pays
guilhem herbert revient sur la situation
à la frontière gréco-turque drapeau
blanc à la main ces migrants la
frontière gréco-turque demande la paix
bloquées dans un no man's land entre les
deux pays
il espérait rentrer en europe mais ont
trouvé une frontière fermée à double
tour
plus tôt dans la matinée le gouvernement
grec diffuser des vidéos de heurts à la
frontière avec la turquie pour recep
tayyip erdogan
l'europe doit prendre sa part du fardeau
depuis le moment où vous aurez vers nos
frontières le nombre de ceux qui se sont
dirigés vers l'europe a atteint les
centaines de milliers et il y en aura
plus bientôt ce nombre s'exprimera en
millions une menace directe pour l'union
européenne qui enverra dès demain des
représentants sur place les
représentants des trois institutions
européennes le parlement le conseil et
la commission c'est à dire le président
david sassoli le président charles
michel et moi même nous rendons semble
en grèce pour témoigner du plein soutien
de l'union européenne comme je les dis
le défi auquel la grèce est confrontée
est un défi européen et la grèce à notre
total soutien
un déplacement pour tenter d'endiguer
cette crise qui laisse des milliers de
migrants sans solution de son côté
angela merkel jugent inacceptable qu
ankara fasse pression sur l'union
européenne sur le dos des réfugiés et
pour en parler nous sommes en direct
depuis londres au royaume uni avec
catherine chaque femme chaque dame
spécialiste du moyen-orient c'est notre
rubrique vu de l'extérieur ce soir
[Musique]
bonsoir une catherine chaque dame merci
d'être avec nous en direct sur rt france
alors pour bien qu'on comprenne parce
que beaucoup de monde en parle mais est
ce qu'on sait vraiment ce que c'est quel
est l'enjeu de ce sketch hausse dès
demain je pense que ça va être très
important pour lui mais surtout pour la
russie parce que la russie avoir des
résultats sur l'a6 et la plus importante
en relation avec la situation
humanitaire mais aussi en termes de la
violation de la souveraineté de la
science la violation du droit
international est encore plus grave le
fait que la turquie utilise la menace
d'une nouvelle vague d'émigration vers
l'europe pour mettre la pression sur la
communauté internationale pour avoir une
influence sur la politique de la région
série et je pense qu'il est important de
souvenir que la russie agit en syrie
à l'invitation de damas la russie n'est
pas en syrie parce que cela infecte et
la russie pas le droit international la
russie a été invitée agit en syrie
médard turquie non et non on pourrait
arguer que la turquie n'a rien à faire
on s'irrite et violet internationale le
turquie la turquie contribuer à ces
problèmes de terrorisme et aussi
influent dans le changement de régime
il est clair que la turquie et la russie
sont très opposées par rapport à la
réalité qu'ils aimeraient instauré en
séries ça très difficile de ces liens je
pense que le sens hier des discussions
avancées sur une bible et la situation
que vit cloîtré chez lui
en dépit de ce que de faire ou menace de
faire je ne pense pas je ne vois pas
pourquoi on changerait de politique
il a insisté sur le fait que la russie a
des intérêts aux séries et n'est pas
prêt à abandonner ce qu'ils ressentent
comme le gouvernement légitime la série
1 dirigée par le président assad
donc ça va et et pourparlers difficiles
justement pour vous qualifier cette
rencontre entre l'émir poutine et le
président turc comme une rencontre de la
dernière chance selon vos amis il est
probable
je pense que les deux présidents ne sont
pas très amis pas en terre c'est le pont
passionnant et sur le plan politique
quant à la vision qu'ils ont pour le
moyen-orient ils ont des visions très
différentes je pense que la russie par
la collaboration avec les gouvernements
en dépit de ces deux récits apprécie ou
pas certaines en politique il ya la
question de ces la la coloration de la
turquie avec les groupes qui attriste sa
vision des questions religieuses et
comment comment gérer ces questions
moyen-orientaux que je pense que cela va
être difficile sans souvent en désaccord
le passé entre la turquie et que de fait
leur propre version de l'histoire
mais cela c'est de la voir s'il est
conscient et de tisser des liens tissés
des liens mais qui tout pour imposer sa
vision du moyen-orient est-ce que
néanmoins je répète mais question un
accord vous semble exclue donc dans ces
conditions vous me décrivez comme
difficile on l'aura compris à don
d'organes je n'ai pas beaucoup d'espoir
mais putin par le passé été traité comme
un camp il fallait qu'il peut être très
souple il y a des chances mais ça va
être difficile je dirais que nous alors
l'europe en prison on est aux mises sous
pression avec la décision de recep
tayyip erdogan de données s'est ouvert
le passage migratoires quel rôle
peut-elle jouer ce qu'elle a une marge
de manoeuvre avec notamment peut-être un
nouvel accord migratoire à négocier très
honnêtement c'est la deuxième fois que
le président r de la migration de masse
comme outil de chantage politique je le
trouve assez révoltant surtout face au
cirque on sait qu'avec la rue risque
le covan a virus et a donc en profiter
sur circonstances je pense que la
communauté internationale doit peser la
possibilité d'un accord constance avec
les coronavirus et
l'impact que cela aura sur les
institutions européennes les capacités
des gouvernements d'accueillir les
nouveaux arrivés il ne s'agit pas
seulement d'accueillir des gens qui
arrivent
ces pays ont besoin d'avoir la capacité
d'accueillir les gens en sécurité non
seulement pour les migrants mais pour
les populations autochtones aussi tous
qu'il est très difficile mais il faut se
souvenir que c'était joué sur la peur de
llauro c'est du chantage certes mais
c'est presque
il s'agit presque du terrorisme ici il
parle depuis sa position officielle et
boutiques
il ne joue pas avec le terrorisme mais à
mon avis il flaire qu'ils firent avec le
terrorisme et c'est une position qui
traitent très dangereuse
merci beaucoup à catherine chaque dame
spécialiste du moyen-orient d'avoir été
avec nous en direct un suaire tesfran ce
soir merci
les discussions entre l'union européenne
et le royaume uni ont débuté le
négociateur de l'ue michel barnier et
son homologue britannique se sont
retrouvés en début d'après midi pour un
entretien d'une heure en donnant
officiellement le coup d'envoi de ces
négociations le break site est acté mais
les détails de la séparation reste à
définir concernant l'énergie le commerce
ou encore la pêche l'un des sujets
majeurs de tension les deux camps ont
jusqu'au 31 décembre 2020 pour se mettre
d'accord
le point en images
oh
[Musique]
[Rires]
mais dans quelques instants rester avec
nous nous reviendrons sur le coronavirus
qui poursuit sa propagation 191 cas
confirmés en france soit 61 de plus en
une journée on apprend que le nombre de
morts monte à 6 aux états unis dans
l'état de washington
bilan officiel ce soir et puis nous
évoquerons toujours aux états unis
le vote demain le super 12 des votes de
14 et america un déterminant vous le
savez pour la course à la primaire
démocrate
[Musique]
en inde il n'existe pas de statistiques
officielles sur les enfants perdus ou
séparés de leurs parents
selon certaines informations un enfant
disparaît toutes les huit minutes dans
le pays
cet enfant est avec vous ou allez vous
[Musique]
elle est avec toi
et lui
il est aussi avec toi il vous accompagne
je ne sais pas je connais pas son nom
selon la commission nationale des droits
de l'homme 44 mille mineurs
disparaissent chaque année
la police déclare qu ils sont 88 mille
enfants le fonds des nations unies pour
l'enfance qualifie cette situation de
génocide et donne le chiffre de 12
millions d'enfants
[Musique]
la france la société afghane ne permet
pas aux femmes d'être libres comme les
hommes les hommes peuvent faire ce
qu'ils veulent mais pas les femmes
[Musique]
nous avons encore besoin d'un garçon en
tout cas j'ai sept filles et pas de fils
[Musique]
en fait seules les filles qui viennent
chez nous et qui joue avec elles savent
que c'est une fille dehors quand elle
joue avec une balle
personne ne s'en rend compte que c'est
une fille et tout le monde croit que
c'est un garçon
pour
[Musique]
nous
les chefs-d'oeuvre de la peinture sont
comme des livres ouverts sur les siècles
passés
les contempler ces découvrir le regard
que portent les artistes sur leur époque
[Musique]
il est un thème qui a toujours eu une
place à part dans l'histoire de l'art
c'est celui de l'enfance
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
que le regard de l'artiste a changé
entre cet enfant iconique peint sous les
traits de jésus par jean fouquet
et cet enfant couvert de toute la
tendresse de sa mère peint par elisabeth
vigée lebrun
entre le regard triste de cette jeune
fille contraint de vendre ses charmes
dans les rues de londres et
l'insouciance de cet enfant à qui le
suisse félix vallotton donne la liberté
de ne même pas regardé le peintre
de l'allemand dürer aux flamands
revendiquent de l'espagnol velasquez au
moderne renoir miro et picasso à travers
toute l'europe du moyen âge au 20e
siècle les grands maîtres de la peinture
n'ont cessé de représenter les enfants
selon les canons de leur époque
[Musique]
nous allons évoquer ici des sujets
stratégiques pour notre pays et sur ces
dossiers sensibles
je vais partager avec vous mon
interprétation quelle que soit la
qualité expertise indéniable nos soldats
ils ne peuvent gagner la guerre pour la
raison que je vais maintenant et vous
que peuvent faire un peu plus de 5000
militaires français à l'efficacité
certes reconnu sur une zone aussi vaste
même renforcé par cinq mille soldats
promis par les pays vieux 5 16
c'est là où les problèmes ont commencé
les déclarations récentes des politiques
des spécialistes des experts des
militaires montre bien que nous sommes
face à une incompréhension totale entre
les différents acteurs
si la france n'a pas la volonté
nécessaire pour assurer la réalisation
de ses objectifs et de les accompagner
par qu'il ne s'agit pas d'imposer il
s'agit de convaincre et d'accompagner il
est à craindre que nous terminions
enlisé dans un conflit sans fin
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous merci de nous rejoindre
pour cette deuxième heure d'émission
tout de suite voici les titres de
l'actualité de ce lundi
191 car désormais de korda virus
confirmé ce soir en france pour trois
décès emmanuel macron bouleverse son
agenda pour se consacrer selon l'elysée
à la gestion l'épidémie en italie la
barre des 50 morts a été franchi le
nouveau le risque de
lié au nouveau coronavirus au sein de
l'union européenne passe dans la
catégorie modérée à élevée aux
etats-unis le score par tuesday ou super
mardi en français c'est pour demain avec
le vote simultanée de 14 états dont la
californie un scrutin qui s'annonce
décisif dans la course à la primaire
démocrate joe biden se présente en
pleine confiance en ayant remporté la
primaire de caroline du sud est en se
plaçant en rival de bernie sanders ces
derniers comptant deux victoires sur
quatre les nonces du recours à l'article
49-3 par edouard philippe a donc été
faite ce week end ce qui a immédiatement
ravivé la colère des opposants à la
réforme des retraites alors que cet
instrument doit permettre à un
gouvernement de mettre en jeu c'est
légitimité face aux députés quand sa
majorité s'opposent à lui n'est-il pas
dévoyée de son sens initial plus grandes
réformes sociales depuis l'après-guerre
peut-elle se passer de discussion ce
sera l'objet de notre face à face à
21h30
le niveau de risque lié aux coronavirus
dans l'union européenne entre désormais
dans la catégorie modéré à élevé
c'est ce qu'a annoncé la présidente de
la commission européenne ursula von der
leyen en france emmanuel macron en
bouleverse son agenda pour se consacrer
selon l'elysée à la gestion de
l'épidémie 691 card coronavirus ont été
recensés sur le territoire ce soir pour
un total de 3 morts écoutez les
précisions de jérôme s'est nommé
directeur général de la santé en france
nous sommes au stade 2 avec un objectif
très clair qui est celui de freiner la
propagation du virus sur le territoire
national en terme de bilan ce jour à 16
heures nous avons selon santé publique
france 191 cas confirmés soit 61 cas de
plus il y a aussi trois décès le
touriste chinois âgés qui est décédé à
paris
l'enseignant de l'oise qui est aussi
décédé à paris et une femme de 89 ans
qui a été testé en post mortem à
l'hôpital de compiègne parmi les cas
confirmés et isolé 107 cas font partie
d'une chaîne de transmission ou d'un cas
groupé 38 proviennent de zones à
l'étranger où circule le virus et au
moins quarante deux sont en cours
d'investigation puisqu'ils ont été
rapportés dans la journée douze régions
ont rapporté des cas cinq régions ont
plus de 10 k et les conséquences du
coronavirus sur l'économie mondiale sont
alarmantes l'inquiétude gagne les places
financières de la planète qui ont vécu
une semaine noire l'os et des yeux
prévoit de son côté une menace
grandissante dans les prochains mois
david khalifa semaine noire krach
boursier crise financière ce sont des
mots que vous avez beaucoup entendu
depuis que l'épidémie du coronavirus
s'étend dans le monde et pour cause
depuis 2008 les marchés européens et
américains n'ont jamais été aussi
chahuté donald trump en personne
s'inquiète et appelle la banque centrale
américaine
à j
eh bien j'espère que la fed interviendra
vous savez que je ne suis pas un grand
fan de la fed ou savez ça je pense
qu'elle fait beaucoup d'erreurs
j'espère que la fête va intervenir et
j'espère qu'elle va intervenir bientôt
regardez l'allemagne il met beaucoup
d'argent ils font probablement encore
plus baisser les taux pour garder
d'autres pays
ils sont tous en train de bourrer la
caisse ils sont tous en train d'aller
vers ça il met beaucoup d'argent
notre fed reste là sans faire ce qu'ils
sont censés faire mais c'est à eux de
décider c'est à eux de décider
ils sont indépendants mais ils ont causé
un grand tort à ce pays les conséquences
vont être importantes si bien que le cpe
dans un rapport publié ce lundi averti
l'économie mondiale est menacée
l'organisation a fait passer sa
prévision de croissance mondiale de 2,9
à 2 4 % pour 2020 elle appelle les états
à agir rapidement pour endiguer la
propagation du virus
l'épidémie de coronavirus est lourde de
conséquences pour les perspectives
économiques
les restrictions à la circulation des
personnes des biens et des services et
les mesures d'endiguement de l'épidémie
tels que les fermetures d usines ont
réduit sensiblement l'activité
manufacturière et la demande intérieure
en chine
les répercussions sur le reste du monde
s'accentue qu'elles soient liées aux
voyages d'affaires et de tourisme ot
chaîne d'approvisionnement aux produits
de base ou au recul de la confiance
le premier secteur touché par l'épidémie
est évidemment le tourisme
particulièrement sensible aux variations
de la clientèle asiatique en effet des
touristes chinois représentent environ
un dixième de tous les visiteurs
transfrontalier le poids de cette
nationalité dans l'ensemble des
touristes arrivant dans certains pays
peut aller bien au delà des passants
même 25% en corée du sud
toujours selon ce même rapport si
l'épidémie continue de se répandre
les coûts seront considérables et leurs
répercussions nombreuses
le tourisme représente un peu plus de
4,25 pour cent de l'économie des pays
membres de l' ocde et 7 % des emplois en
europe la baisse des visiteurs s'est
fortement ressenti c'est depuis janvier
en europe 2000
de nuitées en moins pour l'industrie
touristique européenne et c'est donc à
peu près un milliard d'euros en moins
par mois
le commissaire européen chargé du marché
intérieur également ajouté un risque de
récession en allemagne et en italie
mais il a estimé qu'il était trop tôt
pour avoir des certitudes 1 milliard
d'euros un chiffre qui touche également
la france le ministre de l'économie
bruno le maire s'attend à un impact plus
important sur la croissance française
que ce qu'il prévoyait jusqu'à présent
le seul chiffre que j'ai avancé c'est
0,1 point de croissance en moins pour la
france tant que l'épidémie était limitée
à la chine
maintenant que l'épidémie touche
beaucoup plus de pays notamment la
france et d'autres pays européens
l'impact du coronavirus sur la
croissance française sera beaucoup plus
significatif mais je ne veux pas avancer
de chiffres précis
le gouvernement se tient prêt à prendre
toutes les mesures de soutien
nécessaires pour aider les entreprises à
faire face à cette crise sanitaire avec
l'accélération des mesures radicales
pour tenter d'endiguer le nouveau virus
le fmi a d'ores et déjà abaissé ses
prévisions de croissance une situation
sanitaire mondiale incertaine qui fait
craindre le retour d'une récession
économique
et pour en parler nous sommes avec jean
françois di mailhiot président de
l'institut de recherche asie un centre
bonsoir jean françois di mailhiot avec
vous on va tenter
voilà soit d'être rassurés au contraire
inquiéter peut-être encore plus sur les
conséquences économiques du coroner
virus alors lancé des oeufs et pas
franchement rassurante le coronavirus
mais l'économie mondiale en danger
va brutalement freiné l'économie
mondiale dont la croissance ne devrait
pas dépasser 2 4% selon l' ocde est ce
que vous partagez ce constat assez
alarmiste c'est difficile de passer
derrière l' ocde en termes de pronostic
il faut simplement rappeler ce que c'est
qu'une année normale ou une année
moyenne en termes de croissance mondiale
c'est 3%
on tombe pas de 4 ou 5 % à 2,4 on passe
si pronostic est avérée de 3% certaines
années 3,1 cette année 2,9 à peut-être
2,4 alors c'est pas sans signification
effectivement c'est un chiffre important
qui est pas surprenant si vous prenez un
pays comme la chine qui représente 15%
de l'économie mondiale en termes de pipe
cette année la chine aura fait zéro ou
premier trimestre probablement sur une
année qui était prévu à faire 5 et nuit
ou 6 % de croissance sur l'année
donc soit on a rattrapage et un rebond
d'une économie comme l'économie chinoise
des économies émergentes vont
probablement rebondir
les économies plus traditionnels ont une
élasticité moins grande
c'est à dire qu'elle absorbe le choc
avec plus de temps mais elle remonte
aussi avec plus de lenteur
quelles seraient les conséquences
concrètes notamment en france puisque
alors ça a été ça a été effectivement
chiffrer le chiffre était il a été
rappelé la france encore une fois selon
cette prévision n'entreraient pas en
récession
mais surtout ce qui se passe c'est un
phénomène assez rare c'est à dire que
souvent une récession s'est créé par un
ralentissement de la demande c'est à
dire que le consommateur n'est plus là
et là on a un effet qui va falloir peser
de façon très fine entre eux la
difficulté de satisfaire la demande par
la réfection de l'offre puisque on le
voit les chaînes de production en chine
sont maintenant coupé ou en tout cas
partiellement coupés du reste du monde
donc le ralentissement va venir d'abord
de l'offre ensuite dans certains
secteurs la demande a ralenti mais dans
d'autres secteurs
ça ralentit ras plus tard la confiance
étant le facteur principal de ce
ralentissement
donc on a des facteurs assez atypique
jusqu'ici dans les dernières crises
qu'on a traversé il faut rappeler que
l'action des institutions
internationales
que ce soit en 2008 pour la crise qui
était venu des états-unis ou en 2011
la propagation finalement de la crise
américaine en europe on a eu des
institutions qui ont été très réactives
et qui ont évité le pire
en 2008 on était clairement au bord du
gouffre il faut le rappeler en 2011 2012
on avait un ralentissement très fort
avec des outils nouveaux on a réussi à
éviter
effectivement ces grandes catastrophes
la question c'est quel outil nouveau
va-t-on trouver pour faire l'équilibré
entre ce risque de crise de l'offre
il utilise ce risque de crise de la
demande justement une question peut-être
de deux novices mais est-ce qu'on peut
reproduire le même schéma qu'en 2008 les
institutions comme la bce la fed peuvent
reproduire pour tenter de corriger
objectivement un des facteurs
d'inquiétude c'est naturellement qu'il y
avait en 2008 encore un très grand
consensus international
il faut rappeler que le g20 c'est à dire
ce groupe qui intègre à la fois des pays
développés et puis des pays émergents
qui a intégré la chine
ce g20 il est né de la crise de 2008 on
a évolué progressivement et
principalement aujourd'hui vers une
sorte de fracturation du monde
économique
sinon du monde diplomatique donc ça
c'est déjà une première difficulté
et puis la deuxième ouverte et à la
guerre par exemple trump
la facture est lourde oui ce risque
fracturation du monde qu'on voit un
petit peu partout et puis l'autre
difficulté c'est que les ssii
traditionnelles qu'on a utilisé c'était
des outils de relaxation de la création
monétaire
c'est encore possible on peut toujours
imprimer plus devenait on s'attend à un
consensus de 100 % actuellement sur le
prochain mouvement de la réserve
fédérale américaine qui baisserait ses
taux de 0,5 pour pourcentage point de
pourcentage à 50 points de base
c'est une arme mais il faut probablement
d'autres armes aussi comme celle dont a
parlé bruno le maire l'étalement des
détaxes l'étalement de la tva par
exemple pour les entreprises de façon à
alléger
trésorerie des entreprises qui seraient
engorgé par cette crise de la demande
vous parlez de récession qui selon ses
dernières prévisions de l'oscd
épargnerait la france en tout cas mais
n'épargnerait pas nécessairement
l'italie ou l'allemagne pourquoi ces
deux pays sont plus en danger que
l'allemagne elle a eu d'exposition
majeure à la chine d'ores et déjà donc
l'allemagne
on peut le dire et d'une certaine façon
en danger puisque contrairement aux
autres pays européens
elle n'a pas creusé ce déficit
commercial colossal vis-à-vis de la
chine
elle vend beaucoup à la chine la chine
s'est arrêté d'acheter pratiquement le
15 janvier cette année
donc l'allemagne est frappé par cela
l'italie n'a pas encore retrouvé ses
grands équilibres du fait des
alternances politiques du fait de la
relative instabilité politique et puis
du fait aussi du prix que l'europe lui
fait payer de la crise migratoire c'est
à dire que la litanie bien souvent voir
les européens en disant vous savez c'est
nous qui portons le fardeau de la crise
migratoire depuis le changement de
formule qui a qui a eu lieu il ya
quelques années
évidemment il ya beaucoup d'inquiétude
la part des grands actionnaires mais
aussi des petits porteurs des français
qui aurait pris quelques actions ici ou
là quelle conduite à tenir c'est
compliqué parce que faut peut-être pas
céder à la panique vous nous direz zone
et donc voilà il faut voir la bourse
on s'est beaucoup focalisé sur la bourse
la bourse si vous voulez c'est un
indicateur à la fois avancé de
ralentissement mais aussi de reprise
c'est mais c'est un accélérateur de
sentiments donc la bourse va sur-réagir
systématiquement demain lorsqu'on a vu
ce matin à l'ouverture des bourses
asiatiques qui était rassuré dès que
vous avez un signal positif les bourses
vont rebondir
donc par définition quand on va en
bourse il faut savoir que on est là pour
le moyen terme au moins et certainement
pas pour faire de ce qu'on appelle de
l'infra des trading quand on n'est pas
un professionnel alors bruxelles lundi
vouloir utiliser tous les outils
nécessaires pour protéger l'économie
alors quelle est la marge de manoeuvre
finalement de bruxelles aujourd'hui
et quels sont ces outils effectivement
les outils de bruxelles c'est déjà la
parole on a on a un commissaire thierry
breton qui est un industriel de
formation qui a piloté une très grande
entreprise française avec un succès
extraordinaire mais le ministère de
bruxelles aujourd'hui sachant que
bruxelles ça n'est pas la bce ce n'est
pas la banque centrale européenne qui
fâchent francfort qui coopèrent
naturellement avec les avec les équipes
de bruxelles le ministère de bruxelles
c'est avant tout un ministère de la
parole c'est à dire eh bien nous avons
un certain nombre de questions tout
régler ensemble nous ajustons nos
politiques mais nous n'avons pas de
politique fiscale unifiée en europe et
donc bruxelles ne peut pas jusqu'à
preuve du contraire appuyé sur ce levier
donc c'est un indicateur de confiance
est un indicateur qui lie à un pilote
dans l'avion
au delà de ça c'est surtout la bce qui
va être l'acteur principal
alors vous thierry breton à ce même
série breton qui a chiffré les pertes 1
milliards de manque à gagner par mois
pour le secteur du tourisme on en
parlait aussi dans notre sujet c'est
extrêmement inquiétant
bon alors c'est ça c'est la wii le
secteur du tourisme secteur le sict le
secteur hôtelier les transports comme on
le voit avec l'annulation d'un certain
nombre de lignes régulières par pas mal
de compagnies aériennes y compris en
asie sont des effets à très court terme
avec probablement un effet de rebond dès
que ça repartira un effet de confiance
aussi qu'il sera difficile à
reconstruire mais naturellement les
premiers secteurs touchés
ce sont les secteurs du transport et du
tourisme et donc les pays qui sont très
dépendants
c'est pour ça qu'on parle de la france
effectivement la france ne fait pas que
recevoir des touristes qui viennent
d'autres continents et aussi des
touristes qui traversent la france dans
les 90 millions de touristes qui
viennent en france chaque année il y en
a qui sont en europe dont qui resteront
des touristes de traversant la france
mais pour le reste effectivement ceux
qui viennent de loin vont s'absenter
pendant quelques temps la même ocde on
avait commencé par ça on termine par ce
a affirmé qu'en cas d'épidémie plus
durable et bien là croissance serait
carrément divisé par deux ce sont les
prévisions de l' ocde qu'elle serait
les conséquences pour l'économie en
général et pour notre pays en
particulier
alors déjà les prémisses qui font dire
si l'épidémie durer plus longtemps
bon c'est certainement très conservateur
c'est de notre côté envisager des
hypothèses qui sont entre les mains des
épidémiologistes crois qu'il faut
d'abord écouter ce que disent les
épidémiologistes ainsi non pas une voix
une voix unique qu'il qu'ils se
manifestent
vous avez aussi la croissance qui crée
dans nos secteurs
vous avez aussi des relocalisations qui
vont qui vont arriver si la crise se
prolonge et décision de relocalisation
pourront avoir leurs effets et puis vous
avez des secteurs où on parle du secteur
pharmaceutique qui certes est très
dépendant la chine mais qui
malheureusement d'une certaine façon on
va profiter de la crise les ventes en
ligne secteur de l'économie électronique
vont bénéficier ça donc vous avez aussi
des rééquilibrages le transport est en
train d'augmenter ses prix puisqu'on a
eu une raréfaction des transports
maritimes et donc les prix du fret se
sont remis à augmenter lors qu'ils
étaient en dépression depuis plusieurs
années est-ce que c'est peut-être
l'occasion d'envisager un autre système
ans ex notre système mais ce moment
extrêmement économique est souvent très
très critiqué le capitalisme est ce que
c'est finalement l'opportunité de revoir
un peu sa copie notamment la dépendance
à la chine
certainement c'est effectivement une
situation qui peut permettre cela
ensuite il faut tenir compte de la
brièveté ou de la longueur de la mémoire
des principaux acteurs les acteurs
industriels certainement ont une mémoire
à plus long terme ils font des plans à
moyen terme par les industries soit
lourde ou pas du côté des politiques
c'est plus compliqué parce que très
souvent on agit dans le court terme ont
réagi et on est dans l'action très
rapide donc il est possible aussi qu'au
bout de quelques temps comme ça s'est
passé en 2011 ou 2012
on est oublié qu'on avait traversé une
grande crise il faut aussi le souhaitait
d'une certaine façon que tout cela soit
derrière nous aussi vite que possible
merci en tout cas jean françois di muzio
d'avoir été avec no merci pour votre
analyse
merci
direction maintenant les états unis au
pit beauty djedj à jeter dépenses dans
la course à la primaire démocrate les
médias annoncent également ce soir que
la sénatrice club butcher allait se
retirer et soutenir jo maiden en
caroline du sud justement l'ancien
vice-président distancé de près de 30
points le sénateur du vermont bernie
sanders ont fait le point avec grégoire
douce et et syrie et le bruit la
primaire démocrate est relancé
joe biden en tête et avec une avance
confortable
après un départ au ralenti dans les
états précédent l'ex bras droit de
barack obama est de retour devant ses
partisans
il n'a pas attendu pour se réjouir de sa
première place en caroline du sud où il
a récolté près de 49% des suffrages
[Applaudissements]
il y a quelques jours à peine la presse
et des experts estimé que cette
candidature était morte
maintenant grâce à vous tous le coeur du
parti démocrate
nous venons de remporter une victoire
est une grande victoire grâce à vous
déception en revanche pour celui qui a
connu un démarrage en trombe lors de
cette primaire bernie sanders le
candidat de l'ailé gauche du parti a
récolté seulement 20% des voix mais se
veut optimiste pour la suite et
maintenant nous entrons dans le super
tuesday en virginie et je crois très
fermement que les gens de ce pays pour
le super tuesday et après vont soutenir
notre campagne parce que nous sommes
plus qu'une campagne
nous sommes un mouvement
et c'est dimanche soir que la outsiders
pitbull judge a annoncé son retrait de
la course à l'investiture présidentielle
rappelant que son objectif est de
rassembler les américains face à donald
trump
je prends la décision difficile de
suspendre ma campagne pour la
présidentielle
je ne chercherait plus à être candidat
démocrate à la présidence pour 2020 mais
je ferai tout ce client pouvoir pour que
nous ayons un nouveau président
démocrate en janvier
une annonce surprise qui n'a pas tardé à
faire réagir le président américain
pitbull hadjadj est out
tous ces votes pour le super tuesday
iront à joe biden l'endormi excellent
timing c'est le vrai début de
l'élimination de bernis par les
démocrates
encore une fois pas de nominations
toutefois pas de répit pour les
candidats démocrates toujours en lice
avant le super tuesday qui arrive dès
demain mardi 3 mars
un événement qui constituera forcément
un tournant dans la primaire démocrate
avec 14 et a appelé à se prononcer et
cette annonce de pete bridget
j'interviens dans juste avant le fameux
super tuesday ce sera demain 14 états
qui vont voter en même temps une date
cruciale pour tous les candidats à la
primaire démocrate
[Musique]
et pour en parler nous sommes en direct
avec théo lobry animateurs de bernie
sanders pense bonsoir théo lobry merci
d'être avec nous en direct sur arte
france comment vous abordez ce super
tuesday vous le soutien de bernie
sanders et bien bonsoir merci de me
recevoir
alors ce super tuesday ça va être un
scrutin majeur c'est un scrutin qui va
permettre d'éclaircir les lignes avec
1344 délégués qui vont être en jeu et ça
va surtout permettre et ça permet déjà
de faire le tri entre tous les candidats
et aussi de mesurer le rapport de forces
entre bernie sanders et joe biden on va
avoir aussi l'occasion de mesurer la
force de mike bloomberg
et ça s'annonce en tout cas très très
alléchant et très très chaud justement
quel est votre état d'esprit vous y
allez plutôt optimiste pour votre
poulain et ben je dois dire que il part
favori des sondages puisqu'il a en tête
en californie il est aussi en tête dans
le texas qui est un grand état le grand
état du sud donc qui est un marqueur
important
jusqu'à présent j'ai été plutôt très
confiant pour ce soupir tous des puits
les évènements de ces dernières heures
tendent à à tempérer un peu me ma joie
puisque
amy klobuchar a rendu les armes dans
cette primaire et puis le budget jr et
on sait que tous les deux vont être ce
soir à dallas pour soutenir joe biden
dans sa campagne
la problématique de ce retraité de
candidats c'est que les voix des
centristes ne vont plus être dispersés
comme ce qu'on avait pu l'espérer
du coup il pourrait y avoir un front
commun anti sanders qui est en train de
se dessiner alors justement le même job
hayden qui a déjà remporté la caroline
du sud
comment vous expliquez copie le bit pitt
vous dit gg les sénatrices trop bouchard
porte leur voix sur joe biden et pas sur
bernie sanders qui est pourtant parti
favori vous ne lisiez ah ben c'est assez
simple klobuchar et budget ce sont deux
candidats centristes libéraux bernie
sanders et l'ailé gauche du parti
démocrate
et aujourd'hui beauty djédjé klobuchar
ne veulent pas voir bernie sanders
gagnait beaucoup de voix lors de ce
super tuesday
ils ont sûrement négocier des postes
dans une probable ou possible
administration joe biden et c'est pour
ça qu'ils se sont retirés avant le
scrutin de demain pour laisser le champ
libre à joe biden même si mike bloomberg
est là en tant que trouble-fête et
devrait faire du mal un petit peu à
dubaï tonnes justement le milliardaire
bloomberg on vous y croyez encore
en tant que puissance mais aussi et j'en
veux dire vous le voyez comme un danger
encore et bien paradoxalement mike
bloomberg
pour ce scrutin de demain n'est pas un
danger mais plutôt un atout pour bernie
sanders puisque puisque mike bloomberg
va prendre des voix à joe biden ils sont
sur le même type d'électorat
c'est-à-dire un électorat centriste
modéré comme on dit même si ça ne veut
pas dire grand-chose et mike bloomberg
risque de jouer contre joe biden demain
et c'est là dessus et avec les bons
résultats le bon programme de bernie
sanders que les choses peuvent
être à la faveur du sénateur du vermont
ma dernière question on a appris le
décès de au total 1 6 personnes dans
l'état de washington aux états-unis duo
coronavirus et ce qui a une incidence
pour cette primaire démocrate on sait
qu'il ya beaucoup de rassemblement quand
on fait campagne à priori pas
d'information particulière
actuellement concernant le coronavirus
et les conséquences que cela pourrait
avoir sur la primaire démocrate ou sur
les différents meetings etc
je pense que la conce le le risque
majeur il est avant tout pour le
président des états unis c'est à dire
donald trump qui doit gérer la crise du
code coronavirus chez lui et en cas de
crise mal gérée
cela pourrait lui porter préjudice
d'autant plus que c'est son vice
président mike pence qui est en charge
de gérer cette crise et on sait que my
peines ne crois pas beaucoup à la
science donc on est en mesure de se
demander comment est-ce qu'ils vont
réussir à gérer tout ça merci beaucoup
ôté au labrit d'avoir été avec nous
admirer soeur de bernie sanders france
merci d'avoir été en direct avec nous
dans quelques instants
rester avec mon show sera notre face à
face sur le recours à l'article 49 3
annoncée par le premier ministre ce
week-end le gouvernement et il a voulu
museler l'opposition la plus grande
réforme sociale depuis l'après guerre
peut-être se passer de discussion aux
invités en débattre
[Musique]
le pire je pense en tout cas
politiquement pour l'union européenne
c'est que ça se passe bien pour les
anglais il y aura peut-être un effet
boule de neige si l'italie sort vous
avez un éclatement de l'euro et de
l'union européenne dans les mois qui
suivent
l'euro s'est pas seulement un projet
financier d'un projet politique coaching
l'euro ne fonctionne pas sinon on
n'aurait pas eu un second set elle a eu
avec la grèce je suis pas vraiment pas
d'accord sur l'échec de l'euro
on maintient la grèce en commun à mon
avis c'est une bonne chose ben vous
pouvez pas vous réjouir d'avoir pays qui
est sous perfusion sous assistance
respiratoire en permanence
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je
le lac le plus vieux du monde les lacs
n'ont généralement pas plus de quinze
mille ans
baykal à plus de 25 millions d'années
ici vivent des esprits et des divinités
bouddhiste
l'eau pure et transparente du lac aide
les scientifiques à résoudre des
mystères de l'univers
je vois le baïkal comme un ensemble
cohérent je ne savais pas à quoi
m'attendre ici ce n'est pas que je
découvre quelque chose de nouveau ici je
m'imprègne simplement de tout ce qu'il y
a
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
qu'est ce que tu m'as tu en es et
pourquoi tu m'as tu là qu'est ce que tu
m'as toi qu'est ce tu mac os alors un
vase il vient pas peur
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
21h30 heure française bienvenue sur rc
france si vous nous rejoignez le recours
aux 49 3 relance la contestation sociale
en france l'intersyndicale s'est réunie
ce matin la cgt fo la cftc gc élèves
fait suer solidaire ainsi que les
organisations de lycéens et d'étudiants
appellent à manifester demain partout
dans le pays
aujourd'hui déjà plusieurs milliers de
personnes se sont mobilisées comme ici à
paris ou encore allieront et
manifestants dénoncent ce passage en
force sur la réforme des retraites alors
le 49-3 qui va donc permettre peut-être
d'adopter la réforme des retraites son
vote une arme constitutionnel souvent
utilisé par différents gouvernements et
toujours autant critiqué regarder
[Musique]
une
et en ce fameux article 49 3 de la
constitution alors que cet instrument on
devrait permettre à un gouvernement de
mettre en jeu sa légitimité face aux
députés quand cela majorité s'oppose à
l'huile est il pas aujourd'hui des
voiliers de son sens initial la plus
grande réforme sociale depuis
l'après-guerre peut-elle se passer de
discussion l'opposition at-elle été
muselé ou au contraire
est-elle critiquable c'est l'objet de
notre face à face ce soir et pour en
parler nous sommes avec gérard filoche
ancien inspecteur du travail à ses côtés
sébastien huyghe député les républicains
la 5e circonscription du nord bonsoir à
tous les deux mr enfin d'être là on va
débattre effectivement de cette question
mais avant je vous propose d'écouter les
réactions politiques de tous bords suite
à cette décision un samedi du
gouvernement de faire appel aux 49 3 à
force de mépris pour la démocratie on
prépare la nation à choisir son avenir
hors de la démocratie la meilleure
réponse à ce passage en force du 49 3 et
le 49-3 citoyens ici devant l'assemblée
en face le gouvernement passera t-il ou
lb des parlementaires olb des dans la
rue partout soulevant nous pour sauver
notre protection sociale et la
démocratie
utiliser le 49-3 est un coup de force
contre le parlement
c'est aussi un aveu de faiblesse lundi
nous déposerons une motion de censure
mobilisons-nous une assemblée
constituante devra élaborer une sixième
république
enfin démocratique le gouvernement va
donc imposer une réforme dont le
financement est mystérieux l'impact sur
les français complètement obscur et les
bénéfices sur les finances publiques
absolument pas démontré article 49 3 sur
les retraites
je demande à l'opposition de lancer la
procédure de destitution de macron ce
gouvernement ment de manière éhontée le
temps de débats que nous avons eus sur
la réforme des retraites est très
inférieur à celui de nombreux autres
débats sur les retraites on m'avait
vilipendé pour le mot régime autoritaire
le mot est faible au vu du recours aux
49 3 malgré une majorité de 300 députés
une réforme qui concerne 40 millions de
citoyens un contexte de crise sanitaire
avec un hôpital
public épuisé par le mépris de macron à
chaque étape de la réforme des retraites
le gouvernement aura choisi la pire des
solutions méprisant les français
coupables de ne pas comprendre
l'incompréhensible les syndicats et les
salariés coupable de combattre les
régressions et finalement les
parlementaires voici pour ce florilège
de réactions politiques gérard filoche
on commence par vous seuil elle est plié
cette réforme selon vous vous avez
manifesté aujourd'hui est-ce que
s'affairent encore à quelque chose
oui et il y aura encore beaucoup et
beaucoup de manifestations et cette
réforme ne passera jamais si jamais ils
le font par coup de force au parlement
d'une façon ou d'une autre se dresse
rencontre elle la majorité des salariés
français
on est 30 millions de salariés et 14
millions de retraités il s'agit
brutalement de prendre 20 à 25% nous
retraite de diminuer massivement la
protection sociale et de chasser la
retraite de la protection sociale vous
avez par exemple les organistes enfin
qu'on aborde poule mais les organismes
comme la carte stats qui sont les
gestionnaires des retraites vont être
dissous ça fait concerne treize mille
salariés et donc lille a la volonté
claire macron et philippe de chasser la
retraite de sécurité sociale pour plus
tard la transformer de façon capitaliser
en passant par une fiscalisation et les
raisons du 49 3 2 samedi dernier voire
l'abus du 49-3 tout noir et énervant
parce qu'on le dénonce en fait il faut
supprimer la constitution et le juge moi
je suis pour un régime parlementaire pas
pour un régime présidentiel et je suis
pour contrôler ont décidé collectivement
et que ce soit pas des cadors en haut à
l'elysée qui décide de tout mais après
pourquoi ne l'ont-ils fait parce que ils
ont ils avaient passé l'article 8
on était après la question des régimes
spéciaux on allait aborder les articles
sur le financement les articles sur la
pénibilité
le taux des points etc et donc il
voulait pas affronter l'opinion ni
débattent avec les parlementaires et
leurs propres parlementaires parce que
sedan marche n'ont été prévenus qu'un
quart d'heure avant en décompte leurs
propres députés les méprise à ce point
qu'ils ont su un quart d'heure avant que
et doit filer pas les déposer
le 49-3 donc en vérité c'est parce
qu'ils ne peuvent pas affronter ne
savent pas comment affronter l'opinion
ils sont dans une telle contradiction et
ils ont l'intention de faire tellement
mal en retraite que il faut qu'il le
fasse masqué il ya 180 un changement
dans le texte du gouvernement
parce que les gens ne comprennent pas qu
quand le 49 3 s'impose avec la motion de
censure est repoussée y aura des motions
de censure mais quand elles seront
repoussées cette gouvernement qui écrit
tout seul il a plus la paix s
embarrasser - 10 mai valait sujet parce
qu'on est là pour débattre en apparence
sébastien huyghe eux voilà un gérard
filoche nous a donné ses impressions
d'ensemble vous déjà quelle a été votre
réaction samedi à l'annonce de 149,3
c'est un des mots un des mines
démocratie vous l'avez dit dans le
reportage le 49-3 il n'est pas fait pour
ça il n'est pas fait pour quand on a une
majorité pléthorique et qu'on est sûr
que le texte doit passer pour finalement
faire fi d'un débat au parlement
je pense que emmanuel macron qui n'a
jamais été élu ni élu local ni
parlementaire méprise le parlement en
fait pour lui le parlement ça doit être
une chambre d'enregistrement et ils
trouvent que le parlement c'est un
empêcheurs de gouverner en rond si je
puis dire
d'ailleurs un de ses projets c'était
diminuer le nombre de parlementaires
assez drastiquement pour faire en sorte
que finalement il y ait moins de voix
qui s'élèvent contre ces textes et là on
était dans le cadre d'un débat mais je
pense que c'est sciemment que le
gouvernement avait prévu déjà à l'avance
d'utiliser le 49-3 pourquoi parce que il
y à un instrument qui existe à
l'assemblée nationale qui est le temps
programmé et donc le gouvernement en
déposant six semaines avant son texte
pouvait tout à fait utiliser le temps
programmé où on décide à l'avance le
nombre d'heures de débats et donc chaque
groupe à
un certain temps pour s'exprimer et puis
à l'issue du temps de chacun si jamais
le texte n'est pas finie bien heureux
ont prétendu ses amendements et puis on
finit le texte plus rapidement ça peut
empêcher des débats de s'éterniser
puisque apparemment le problème du
gouvernement c'est que pour lui il est
le le le temps du débat s'éternise et or
alors c'est vrai que voilà vous en
parlez pas tous les deux mais ya quand
même eu plus de 40 mille amendements
c'est vrai qu'on avait du mal à rentrer
dans les débats
est-ce que l'opposition n'a pas rendu
justement mauvais service aux opposants
très nombreux de ce chrono défendez 90
parce que c'était une occasion
magnifique pour le gouvernement de dire
ben voilà il ya pas de débat non on y va
on passe en force gfi rejet en fait
prenez les amendements pour le mariage
tous tous pour tous il ya six ans et
cinq fois plus
c'est arrivé dix fois dans l'histoire
c'était soit d'amendements souvenez-vous
en 2003 jean louis debré il avait sorti
tous les piles d'amendements autour de
lui au perchoir il y avait des dizaines
de milliers d'amendements et pourtant on
est allé jusqu'au bout de la discussion
du texte et il disait d'ailleurs qui je
me plaignais à l'époque j'étais jeune
député je disais mais ce blocage
parlementaire est insupportable et il
avait eu cette phrase qui reste m'a
remarqué dans ma mémoire c'est le
parlement est fait pour parlementer
et si on parlemente pas dans le dans
l'assemblée nationale au sénat
et bien c'est dans la rue que vont
sceller gmail majorité fédérale ont
démâté pas du fond débattent et voilà
sur des virgules
un petit mot tout non mémoire d'anne
étrangères de l'année dernière seconde
du temps
et qu'est-ce qu'il a fait macron trois
mois et demi de débats à lui tout seul
il faisait le tour de france on avait sa
droite en étaient les dix heures par
jour et la trois mois et demi et là
qu'un jour il peut plus supporter je
vous dire il se moque du monde
c'est pas possible et je vous signale
que il voulait faire la réforme des
retraites après les municipales
il était prévu initialement aussi trois
mois de débats jusqu'à l'été ils ont
abandonné tout ça
ils ont eux mêmes magouilles et déformé
changer leur tête parce qu'il faut venir
sur le fond il est question qui est plus
de référence au trimestre c'est-à-dire
qu'il y ait plus que la chaque point
attention c'est plus qu'une révolution
c'est une contre-révolution y aura plus
le lien avec le travail
c'est le nombre de points acquis et vous
devrez atteindre une espèce de concours
au point pour arriver à avoir une
retraite à ses taux avant de mourir et
avoir assez d'essence pour pouvoir vivre
mais tout est fait en dépit des bons
sens tout est fait en débutant on peut
débuter en dépit du bon sens il y avait
un haut commissaire qui a été chargé
pendant deux ans de faire le débat avec
l'ensemble des représentants
j'en parle avec l'ensemble des
représentants syndicaux avec l'ensemble
des branches voilà pendant deux ans elle
n'avait pas eu de négociations et à
l'issue il a rendu son rapport et qu'a
fait le gouvernement et on recommence la
concertation est en fait le problème
c'est qu'il n'ya pas de concertation
quand vous faites venir les gens vous
les fait s'exprimer mais vous ne les
entendez pas vous avez votre projet qui
est préparé et vous n'allez pas le
bouger parce que vous savez exactement
ce que vous le voulez à la fin des
discussions alors ils pavillon du
problème s'est enrichi de tous les
acquis de la négociation avec les
partenaires sociaux et les arrivants si
on vous invite à une table de
négociation
on vous dit asseyez-vous on a le temps
et en fait on dit en faux c'est déjà
fini
on a déjà vendu la table de négociation
on a déjà vendu la chaîne sur laquelle
vous êtes assis et on a déjà préparé la
salle pour une autre réunion et ça vous
appelez ça négociations une négociation
c'est quand vous avez des partenaires
qui ont chacun un point de vue différent
et on cherche à le rapprocher cela on
trouve quelque chose au milieu la
méthode macron phillips et vous avez des
partenaires qui ont un point de vue
différent et il se rapprochera l'ont
jamais que les autres c'est à dire que
eu égard ont le même à la sortie qu'à la
fin et en plus ce que je viens dirais
même pas tout à fait vrai parce qu'ils
vont changer eux à leur façon quand ça
leur convient de ce qu'ils vont mettre
dans le texte sans écouter les autres et
selon des pressions dans des petits
cercles qui s'échappe
tellement à la démocratie et au
gouvernement sébastien vite pour vous
c'est pas un grand gâchis quand même
parce que ce qui vous différencie quand
même de gérard filoche c'est que vous
vous souhaitiez chez les républicains
quand même cette réforme des retraites
un saut souviens quand même du programme
de françois fillon
et voilà 65 ans et elle a du coup c'est
vrai que c'est nous voulons une réforme
des retraites mais pas celle-là c'est à
dire que le problème c'est que on veut
mettre sous la même toise des gens qui
ont des parcours et des situations
différentes
c'est ce qu'ils appellent le système
universel
sauf que tout le monde n'est pas ne peut
pas être logé à la même enseigne avec
des parcours différents vous pouvez pas
mettre en sens sous un même régime des
salariés des fonctionnaires des
professions indépendantes parce que les
parcours les temps de parcours les
rémunérations les modalités de calcul de
rémunérations la même joie mais j'ai
bien dit quand nous nous on n'est pas
favorable au système par points
on était favorable à faire en sorte
qu'ils aient une convergence des régimes
c'est à dire que compte qu'on puisse
conserver des régimes différents avec
des spécificités mais pas faire des
écarts tels qu'ils existaient par
exemple entre le régime par exemple des
cheminots et puis le régime des salariés
ou des fonctionnaires donc il fallait
faire ce qu'on avait commencé avec
nicolas sarkozy c'est à dire une
convergence des différents régimes
en prenant en compte les spécificités de
chacun un jardinage moi je soutiens la
motion de censure de la gauche unie
c'est bien qu'il soit unie parti
communiste parti socialiste et la france
en sont mises ensemble des pauses la
même motion de censure qui n'est pas la
même que vous monsieur mais parce que
moi c'est possible quand même très bas
pour que
le retour à la retraite à 60 ans moi à
taux plein est indexée sur les salaires
indexés sur les prix et pas de retraite
inférieure au smic parce que c'est le
camp vous passé de 59 à 60 ans si vous
prenez votre retraite à 60 ans le prix
du gaz il diminue pas le prix
d'électricité diminue pas le prix de
votre téléphone il diminue pas votre
loyer et diminue pas alors je vois pas
pourquoi un retraité aurait un niveau
inférieur au smic ou alors on ne traite
pas comme un un sale ailleurs la
retraite et un salaire continué la
retraite et un salaire à vie et c'est
fondamental qu'il en soit ainsi et le
halal à comprendre comme un ennemi un
impôt ni une épargne elle va en direct
de ceux qui travaillent à ceux qui ne
travaillent plus mais le projet est plus
fort que les paroles et les pensions le
problème c'est solide et fiable
le problème c'est quand le nombre
d'actifs par rapport au nombre de
retraités est inversement
proportionnelle au temps et donc jusqu'à
du vampire problème
la problématique je vous ai écoutés la
problématique c'est de faire comme en
deux c'est de savoir comment on finance
le système des retraites et et
d'ailleurs quand je vous disais que tout
à fait tout a été fait à l'envers dans
cette réforme des retraites c'est on
nous fait voter discuter un texte donc à
l'assemblée nationale alors que la
conférence de financement aura lieu
après c'est à dire que on a pas on
connaît pas les moyens dont on va
disposer pour faire la réforme de
retraites alors que il y aurait fallu il
y aurait fallu pardon que la conférence
des financements se soit achevée qu'un
accord ait été trouvé sur lui
financement pour déterminer la manière
dont votre calendrier
finalement le tout est fait à l'ombre de
sébastien huyghe plus que de fond du
problème
non je pense que encore une fois que ce
soit pour emmanuel macron mais aussi
pour l'ensemble du gouvernement
le parlement étant une chambre
d'enregistrement on veut faire
enregistrer
simplement la réforme des retraites par
le parlement pour pouvoir dire voilà
elle a été faite maintenant trouver les
moyens de financer
et vous n'allez pas les trouver donc on
va l'imposer il faut se souvenir qu'il
ya quand même dans ce texte prévu 17
commandé 17 heures donne enfin 29-29
maintenant non mais c'est parce que à
chaque fois il ya des amendements qui
augmente le nombre d'ordonnancés donc on
s'y perd mais donc ça veut dire que à 29
reprises le gouvernement va décider tout
seul de la manière dont va finalement
être appliqué la réforme lors le
gouvernement fin stratège ou tout
simplement assez inconscient et
suicidaire parce qu'on sait que la
majorité des français sont contre ce
projet de réforme
si le gouvernement passe en force quelle
sera selon vous les conséquences c'est
un gouvernement fanatiques les idées
viennent de loin ce soir jean luc
mélenchon des ce sont les fesses ou de
fonder les gens qui sont ultra libéraux
ils viennent à la retraite par points
vous savez c'est pas suédois cesser
d'utiliser pinochet
ça y est c'est le libéralisme dans toute
son horreur cda qui a pas de budget
séparé pour les retraités on va aller
fiscalisés puis ensuite après démanteler
cela bon et vous c'est pas une question
de financement la retraite c'est une
question de bonne heure c'est une
conception sociale pour moi faut d'abord
que les gens puissent l'espérance de vie
en bonne santé de 63 et 64 ans et si
elle allonge l'espérance de vie tout
court c'est parce qu'on à la retraite à
60 ans si on travaille plus longtemps on
aura plus tôt et si on vit plus
longtemps en fait c'est pour en profiter
plus longtemps
d'abord cette conception puis après faut
régler les gifles moi je dis comment on
peut régler les chiffres il faut moduler
les cotisations pour regarder la
prestation
c'est à dire la prestation si vous dites
60 ans est un choix social
eux ils disent pas plus de 14% du pib'
moi je dis pas plus de 60 ans ont fait
ronde aura du boulot aux jeunes et pour
garder les 60 ans au module les
prestations c'est dans les cotisations
sociales et je termine parce que l'idée
au fond cette fois d'une seconde c'est
que c'est basé sur le salaire les
salaires sont bloqués depuis plus de 20
ans les cotisations depuis plus de
trente ans vous modules et de 0,1 0,2
point 0,5 point la cotisation et tout le
monde est en retraite à 60 ans
sauf que l'erreur fondamentale c'était
de passer de la retraite de 65 ans à 60
ans du temps de mitterrand au nom
s'était ouvert en réalité lorsque tous
les autres pays
finalement on fait le chemin inverse
parce que pour financer les retraites il
faut travailler plus longtemps puisque
l'espérance de vie a augmenté chez les
français donc il ya nécessité de
travailler plus longtemps et en plus
sans y arriver dans de chômeurs et en
plus si vous voulez le fait de
travailler plus longtemps
il n'y a que comme ça que le financement
permet
de d'équilibrer le système et puis en
plus la pénibilité existent beaucoup
moins que par le passé et donc il ya
mené on est capable de travailler plus
longtemps
on m'a plus longtemps en meilleure santé
et encore une fois parce que le nombre
d'actifs par retraité a beaucoup a
beaucoup diminué
chacun de ces actifs produits plus donc
c'est suffisant pour pouvoir payer
la france n'a jamais été aussi riche et
les richesses aussi mal partagée et en
ce qui concerne la pénibilité
elle a pris des formes totalement
différente mais voudra vous restez 7h30
devant un bureau vos chances de mourir
d'une embolie pulmonaire augmente vos
chances de mourir d'une crise cardiaque
augmente il ya deux cent cinquante mille
accidents cardiaques mon bureau 170
mille accidents cardiaques et
vasculaires par an la moitié sont dues
au travail
la sexologie vient de tomber pour 2018
vous avez 5 151 morts au travail en 2018
y'a pas une télévision qui fait une
enquête qui fait un déroulé sur cette
question pour si on les fout les roseaux
vie continue mais elle loppement
énonçant que des rentiers en bonne santé
elle diminue et l'espérance de vie elle
est inégal il ya 13 ans d'écart entre
les plus riches et les plus pauvres et 7
ans d'écart entre les ouvriers et les
cadres donc en vérité l'espérance de vie
ne peut pas être un critère ce qui doit
être un critère c'est comment
massivement ceux qui ont beaucoup
travaillé durement
alors dans le bâtiment je suis très
clairement à l'artel de tête à 55 ans et
je suis sûr que personne ne peut
s'opposer à cela et quand on vient n'y a
pas d'art rien n'empêche de dix mille
pattes en considération la pénibilité
est abrité dans un bâtiment sika aussi
les habitudes alimentaires il ya la
sédentarité et il ya beaucoup
il ya beaucoup de critères qui dit soeur
de 17 ans soeur de ballet de l'opéra
tiarei du vienna en vie dans cette
opération et à partir du moment où l'on
sait sur allier des danseurs certains
ont quand même eu quelques concessions
d'ailleurs c'est un petit peu ce qui ce
qui frappe ici alors les avocats
continuent à manifester
manifestement ils n'ont rien venu selon
eux les pompiers ont tenu les danseurs
va avoir 100 régimes spéciaux au lieu de
parce que ils lâchent des fausses
miettes à chacun des systèmes en pensant
que toute façon comme on calculera les
retraites sur 43 ans au lieu de sur les
25 meilleures années
de toute façon il arrivera à baisser
donc même quand il lâche à tel ou tel
secteur pour pas parce qu'il a peur
bon c'est le capot des policiers les
policiers il a lâché tout garder
l'ancien système mais de tous si la
retraite est calculée sur quarante trois
ans les gens perdront quand même ça et
alors nos jours j'avais je rappelle là
on est d'accord
oui bah j'ai besoin de vous dire quelque
chose avait une infirmière qui savent et
qui s'occupait de moi et à me dire mais
moi monsieur fils je vais quand même
avoir les 1000 euros ici mais maintenant
vous avez travaillé a mis 25 ans je vais
vous les aurez pas il vous faut une
carrière complète et maintenant sur
dakar ja complètement ça c'est le
minimum 1000 euros c'est ça fait partie
du projet vous y croyez vous aimez vous
les avez pas si vous n'avez pas fait 43
ans donc en vérité vous n'êtes pas sur
des mille euros c'est pas un minimum
faut avoir la carrière il présente une
forme de garantie
ah non bah non c'est c'est pour une
carrière complète
et d'après ce que je comprends il va
encore y avoir des nouveautés parce que
ça échapperait au covan au parlement
mais il est question de remplacer de
dire pour carrière complète nombre de
points taire de ne plus faire référence
aux 43 ans
d'après ce que je me suis laissé dire je
suis pas au parlement et j'ai pas les
derniers textes du gouvernement mais
paraît qu'il va dans ce sens puisqu'il a
fait lui-même 182 changements à son
propre mandat qui risquent de se finir
avec cette affaire dutroux ou est ce
qu'ils ont trouvé 113 milliards de trou
au début dans sa campagne électorale
macron dix ans il n'y a pas de problème
financier pour les retraites vous pouvez
le lire c'est dans son livre noir sur
blanc
après disait nous ne toucherons pas au
niveau des retraites ni l'âge de départ
pouvait lire c'était dans son programme
cet homme là était un menteur
bon et maintenant ils trouvent 113000
airbus viennent ces 113 milliards
d'argent que le gouvernement a pris dans
les caisses de protection sociale
séparés et qu'il n'y en avait plus c'est
donc en vérité ils creusent le trou
artificiellement et 113 milliards c'est
pour sept ans depuis quand on calcule
sur sept ans ça veut dire 12 milliards
par an mais 12 milliards par an sur une
retraite qui coûte 3 114 milliards c'est
très peu finalement c'est très relatif
donc en vérité pourquoi changer tout ça
pour un système de financement on
inventa trop qui n'existe pas et où on
fait peur aux gens et enfin on va leur
dire je casse tout votre système
et puis c'est moi qui vais décider
combien je vous paye à la problématique
également c'est sur la valeur du point
c'est à dire que lorsqu'on gens
pleuraient qu'on considérera que le
système est trop onéreux et qu'il est en
déficit
eh bien il suffira de de diminuer la
valeur des points pour diminuer les
dépenses et en réalité ces 10 po
diminuer les retraites de nos
concitoyens ils seront créés l'un vers
nantes d'asselah saint-juéry de la
grille de fer mais et le problème c'est
que emmanuel macron avait mis ça dans
son programme le fait de faire une
réforme par craint il voulait faire une
réforme systémique parce que ça fait un
de faire une réforme
ça veut dire eux personne parce que vous
avez voulu là c'est la droite qui
n'avaient pas répliqué moi mais ça bien
sûr les mains de m
non non pas du tout la réforme elle a
été fait on l'a fait en 2003 on l'a fait
on en 2012-2013 avec nicolas sarkozy qu
on a fait les réformes qui étaient
nécessaires pour pérenniser
c'est nous qui avons introduit le
système des carrières longues ou les
gens travailler à 14 15 16 17 ans et
bien pouvait partir plus tôt à la
retraite
donc on a fait ces réformes ont ailleurs
à allonger la durée de travail de 60 à
62 ans et c'était une première phase et
ça voulait dire que par la suite que une
réforme des retraites
elle n'est pas figée à 8m dans dans dans
le marbre presque les circonstances
changent et qui le nécessitent et de la
faire évoluer pour garder le système
auquel les français sont attachés et a
raison c'est le système par répartition
et donc il y a besoin de réformer mais
pas n'importe quelle réforme pas faire
la réforme pour la réforme
c'est une réforme qui doit être au
bénéfice des français avec un système
qui doit être pérennisé où on garantit
un niveau de vie à nos concitoyens
aujourd'hui cette garantie de niveau de
vie n'existe pas dans la réforme telle
qu'elle est
c'est aujourd'hui qu'on parle de justice
sociale et pas nécessairement de niveau
de vie gérard filoche le mot de la fin
par oui non
je suis d'accord et vous quand vous
dites effet un système par points pour
faire bien non ce son plan global et de
supprimer toutes les cotisations
sociales et dont ce qu'il fait sur la
retraite il fera pour la sécurité
sociale santé après son projet global et
d'arrêter d'avoir un budget séparé de la
protection sociale ses 820 milliards et
de le fondre dans le budget de l'état de
ne plus avoir d'aller les faits s'est
séparé du dieu de la du projet de loi de
budget et quand tu leurs amis tous dans
un même tonneau je dis toujours il
mettra une tirette en bas il pourra
choisir ce qui fait de l'argent bien
s'il veut faire deux porte avions
nucléaire à la place de 100 hôpitaux il
le fera et c'est ce qu'il faut que tout
le monde comprenne
il a déjà enlevé les cotisations
restaurant sur hommage à c'est à dire
il a fait ça va être une tuerie un j'ai
déjà eu l'occasion de le dire à partir
du 1er avril vous avoir les gens dehors
et grands des auto-entrepreneurs dans la
rue à faire des crêpes des choses comme
ça parce qu'ils seront même plus
inscrits sur les chômages et vous aurez
au lieu de deux millions trois cent
mille chômeurs indemnisés vous allez
avoir un million deux cent mille
après vous truqué les chiffres du
chômage parce que vous n'y sont plus
dedans ils sont indépendants
mais deux ensuite après quand tu leur
arrivée chômage il va régler la retraite
il réglera le sort de la sécu c'est pour
ça qu'il veut pas faire concessions sont
les hôpitaux aujourd'hui et c'est pour
ça qu'ils doutent place en pleine crise
en pleine menace de pandémie qui nous
place dans une situation absolument
dramatique
merci en tout cas à tous les deux gérard
filoche à sébastien huyghe et d'avoir
des 28 c'est la fin de cette émission on
se retrouve dans quelques minutes pour 1
point complet sur l'actualité
[Musique]
nous allons évoquer ici des sujets
stratégiques pour notre pays et sur ces
dossiers sensibles
je vais partager avec vous mon
interprétation quelle que soit la
qualité expertise indéniable nos soldats
ils ne peuvent gagner la guerre pour la
raison que je vais maintenant est ce que
peuvent faire un peu plus de 5000
militaires français à l'efficacité
certes reconnu sur une zone aussi vaste
même renforcé par cinq mille soldats
pour lui par les pays vieux 5 da selaou
les problèmes ont commencé
les déclarations récentes des politiques
des spécialistes des experts des
militaires montre bien que nous sommes
face à une incompréhension totale entre
les différents acteurs
si la france n'a pas la volonté
nécessaire pour assurer la réalisation
de ses objectifs et de les accompagner
par qu'il ne s'agit pas d'imposer il
s'agit de convaincre et d'accompagner il
est à craindre que nous terminions
enlisé dans un conflit sans fin
[Musique]
cette histoire est étroitement liée à la
culture
c'est l'histoire d'une communauté
nollywood est un groupe de personnes qui
veulent vraiment raconter leur histoire
c'est comme sortir avec un homme marié
oui c'est comme de sortir avec un homme
marié tu dois le faire vite et pas cher
si tu le fais vite
cela signifie que ce n'est pas cher
[Musique]
si tu veux faire des affaires ok ok est
coupée
on ne se sent pas protégés c'était si
ces terribles qu'on ne pouvait pas
dormir la nuit
[Musique]
mais nous vivions heures jusqu'à ce que
la violence soit venu frapper à notre
porte
quand ils venaient ils pouvaient choisir
une femme à leur goût que la violer et
tuer son mari
il faisait tout ce qu'il voulait il se
croyait au dessus de la loi 7000 un
groupe d'hommes armés est entré chez moi
par effraction ils voulaient nous violer
moi et mes enfants
donc on était obligé de fuir j'ai fait
mes valises et je suis allé à carthagène
personne n'a réussi à m'en dissuader
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à chaque scène de ce spectacle raconte
l'histoire de l'une de ces femmes
l'histoire de la souffrance que la
violence sexuelle que beaucoup d'entre
elles ont enduré c'est passionel
histoire de meurtre et du fait d'être
chassé de son foyer
diomi c'est comment la dette pour alan
doss voilà ce que ça représente ici
[Musique]
191 cas de coronavirus confirmé ce soir
en france dont 3 décès mais neymar ont
bouleversé son agenda penso consacré
souvent les misères et gestion
l'épidémie en italie la barre des 50
morts a été franchi deux niveaux de
risques liés aux nouveaux navires us au
sein de l'union européenne passe dans la
catégorie modéré à élevé nouveau départ
à la république en marche le député du
rhône hubert julien laferrière claque la
porte du parti en raison de l' usage du
49-3 les manifestations attendues demain
en france à l'intersyndicale appelle à
des mobilisations partout
elle entend protester contre le recours
à cet article
deux motions censure déposée par
l'opposition contre le gouvernement
seront débattus à l'assemblée la
différence de financements et fo vient
d'annoncer qu'il a quittée recep tayyip
erdogan rencontrera béni rouquine jeudi
à moscou le président en turquie
espérait parvenir avec son homologue
russe un cessez le feu en syrie les
migrants continuent d'appuyer d'affluer
vers la grèce depuis que la turquie a
ouvert sa frontière
un gala merkel qui juge inacceptable en
carafe fasse pression sur je cite le dos
des réfugiés
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue si vous nous
rejoignez en direct sur rt france le
niveau de risque lié au corona virus
dans l'union européenne entre désormais
dans la catégorie modéré à élevé c'est
ce qu'a annoncé la présidente de la
commission européenne ursula von der
leyen en france emmanuel macron
bouleverse son agenda pour se consacrer
selon l'elysée à la gestion de
l'épidémie
191 cas de corona virus ont été recensés
sur le territoire ce soir pour un total
de 3 morts écoutez les précisions de
jérôme s'est nommé directeur général de
la santé en france nous sommes au stade
2 avec un objectif très clair qui est
celui de freiner la propagation du virus
sur le territoire national en terme de
bilan ce jour à 16 heures nous avons
selon santé publique france 191 cas
confirmés soit 61 cas de plus il y a
aussi trois décès le touriste chinois
âgés qui est décédé à paris
l'enseignant de l'oise qui est aussi
décédé à paris et une femme de 89 ans
qui a été testé en post mortem à
l'hôpital de compiègne parmi les cas
confirmés et isolé 107 cas font partie
d'une chaîne de transmission ou d'un cas
groupé 38 proviennent de zones à
l'étranger où circule le virus et au
moins quarante deux sont en cours
d'investigation puisqu'ils ont été
rapportés dans la journée douze régions
ont rapporté des cas cinq régions ont
plus de dix cas elle 61 nouveaux cas ont
donc été rapportés aujourd'hui en france
parmi les départements les plus touchés
l'oise mais aussi le morbihan à paris le
salon du tourisme et du livre sont
annulés louvre est fermé françois disque
est vite ch
écoles fermées et arrêté interdisant
tout rassemblement collectif jusqu'au 14
mars dans le morbihan
la préfecture a décidé de prendre des
mesures cinq mille sept cents élèves
seront ainsi privés de cours pour le
moment mon arrêté
c'est donc quatorze jours ci du 1er au
14 en fait à l'instar de ce qui a été
fait dans l'oise comme dans haute savoie
il n'y a pas de jauge en fait les
rassemblements dans un lieu fermé sont
interdit les rassemblements de masse
sont interdits de fer que nous pussions
éviter la programme préparation rapide
du virus établissements scolaires
également fermés dans l'oise à
crépy-en-valois l'un des foyers de
propagation
les habitants prennent leurs précautions
sans pour autant s'alarmer
chamakh est pas plus qu'aux non
je suis zen non on verra par la suite
mais pour l'instant ça va
en plus on se lavait les mains plus
souvent aussi bon là je vais jouer au
sort de la pharmacie j'ai réussi à avoir
un petit flacon l'afjel bon ben on m'a
conseillé de plutôt de remettre bon ben
je fais plutôt remettre un peu vu voilà
sur la main et puis si je rentre à la
maison en espérant que tout se passe
bien
à paris certains événements sont d'ores
et déjà annulés
c'est le cas du salon du livre qui
devait se dérouler du 23 mars le musée
du louvre lui est resté fermé après le
vote d'un nouveau droit de retrait par
le personnel de quoi décevoir les
touristes est-ce que je pense que c'est
une bonne raison pour fermer le musée
n'en est vraiment pas elle préférait
être à l'intérieur on fait un long
voyage pour venir ici je ne suis pas sûr
que la fermeture du muscles et arrêtent
la propagation les transports en commun
ne sont pour l'instant pas impactés des
restrictions sont envisagées en cas de
passage au stade 3 de l'épidémie le
seuil d alerte maximum
mais aucun arrêt du trafic vous avez
compris que ces plans de continuité
d'activité
il vise à trouver le meilleur équilibre
entre le fait de constater qu'on a un
virus qui peut circuler
à ce stade trois plus largement dans la
population qu'il faut évidemment
ralentir la progression de ce virus et
en même temps il s'agit pas d'arrêter le
pays
il faut que chaque français devienne un
acteur de ce combat contre le corona
ce a appelé de son côté edouard philippe
lors d'une visite d'un centre
hospitalier de bordeaux pour le premier
ministre se laver les mains toutes les
heures et d'ailleurs probablement la
meilleure façon de le faire
pour les conséquences du coronavirus sur
l'économie mondiale sont alarmantes
l'inquiétude gagne les places
financières de la planète qui ont vécu
une semaine noire l' ocde prévoit de son
côté une menace grandissante dans les
prochains mois david khalifa au krach
boursier crise financière ce sont des
mots que vous avez beaucoup entendu
depuis que l'épidémie du corona virus
s'étend dans le monde et pour cause
depuis 2008 les marchés européens et
américains n'ont jamais été aussi
chahuté donald trump en personne
s'inquiète et appelle la banque centrale
américaine agir et bien j'espère que la
fed interviendra
vous savez que je ne suis pas un grand
fan de la fed vous savez ça je pense
qu'elle fait beaucoup d'erreurs mais
j'espère que la fed va intervenir et
j'espère qu'elle va intervenir bientôt
vous regardez l'allemagne
il met beaucoup d'argent il faut
probablement encore plus baisser les
taux pour garder d'autres pays
ils sont tous en train de bourrer la
caisse ils sont tous en train d'aller
vers ça il met beaucoup d'argent
un autre fed reste là sans faire ce
qu'ils sont censés faire mais c'est à
eux de décider c'est à eux de décider
ils sont indépendants mais ils ont causé
un grand tort à ce pays
les conséquences vont être importantes
si bien que l' ocde dans un rapport
publié ce lundi averti l'économie
mondiale est menacée
l'organisation a fait passer sa
prévision de croissance mondiale de 2,9
à 2,4 pour cent pour 2020 elle appelle
les états à agir rapidement pour
endiguer la propagation du vih
l'épidémie de coronavirus est lourde de
conséquences pour les perspectives
économiques
les restrictions à la circulation des
personnes des biens et des services et
les mesures d'endiguement de l'épidémie
tels que les fermetures d'usinés ont
réduit sensiblement l'activité
manufacturière et la demande intérieure
en chine
les répercussions sur le reste du monde
s'accentue qu'elles soient liées aux
voyages d'affaires et de tourisme ot
chaîne d'approvisionnement aux produits
de base ou au recul de la confiance
le premier secteur touché par l'épidémie
est évidemment le tourisme
particulièrement sensible aux variations
de la clientèle asiatique en effet des
touristes chinois représentent environ
un dixième
de tous les visiteurs transfrontalier le
poids de cette nationalité dans
l'ensemble des touristes arrivant dans
certains pays peut aller bien au delà
des passants même 25% en corée du sud
toujours selon ce même rapport si
l'épidémie continue de se répandre
les coûts seront considérables et leurs
répercussions nombreuses le tourisme
représente un peu plus de 4 25% de
l'économie des pays membres de l' ocde
et 7 % des emplois en europe la baisse
des visiteurs s'est fortement ressenti
c'est depuis janvier en europe 2
millions de nuitées en moins pour
l'industrie touristique européenne et
c'est donc à peu près un milliard
d'euros en moins par mois
le commissaire européen chargé du marché
intérieur a également ajouté un risque
de récession en allemagne et en italie
mais il a estimé qu'il était trop tôt
pour avoir des certitudes 1 milliard
d'euros un chiffre qui touche également
la france le ministre de l'économie
bruno le maire s'attend à un impact plus
important sur la croissance française
que ce qu'il prévoyait jusqu'à présent
le seul chiffre que j'ai avancé c'est
0,1 point de croissance en moins pour la
france tant que l'épidémie était limitée
à la chine
maintenant que l'épidémie touche
beaucoup plus de pays notamment la
france et d'autres pays européens
l'impact du coronavirus sur la
croissance française sera beaucoup plus
significatif mais je ne veux pas avancer
de chiffres précis
le gouvernement se tient prêt à prendre
toutes les mesures de soutien
nécessaires pour aider les entreprises à
faire face à cette crise sanitaire avec
l'accélération des mesures radicales
pour tenter d'endiguer le nouveau virus
le fmi a d'ores et déjà abaissé ses
prévisions de croissance une situation
sanitaire mondiale incertaine qui fait
craindre le retour d'une récession
économique répond jean françois di
mailhiot président de l'institut de
recherche asia centre sont la chine la
croissance économique mondiale et
lourdement impacté sur l'année il faut
simplement rappeler ce que c'est qu'une
année normale ou une année moyenne en
termes de croissance mondiale ces 3 % on
tombe pas de 4 ou 5 % à 2,4 on passe si
le pronostic est avérée de 3% certaines
années 3,1 cette année 2,9 à peut-être
deux
4 alors c'est pas sans signification
effectivement c'est un chiffre important
qui est pas surprenant si vous prenez un
pays comme la chine qui représente 15%
de l'économie mondiale en termes de pipe
cette année la chine aura fait zéro ou
premier trimestre probablement sur une
année qui était prévu à faire 5 et nuit
ou 6 % de croissance sur l'année
donc soit on a rattrapage et un rebond
d'une économie comme l'économie chinoise
et d'économies émergentes vont
probablement rebondir
les économies plus traditionnels ont une
élasticité moins grande
c'est à dire qu'elle absorbe le choc
avec plus de temps mais elle remonte
aussi avec plus de lenteur
les premiers foyers en europe quitte à
les enregistrer près de 500 nouveaux cas
en 24 heures la barre des 50 décès a été
dépassé à 2700 personnes testées
positives au total ailleurs dans le
monde les etats unis déplorent un
sixième or tous les dans tout l'état de
washington
second pays le plus touché après la
chine la corée du sud qui recense et
près de 600 cas supplémentaires au total
près de 4300 contamination et séoul qui
a décidé de porter plainte pour homicide
contre les leaders d'un mouvement
religieux qu'elle accuse de ne pas avoir
permis d'empêcher la propagation
d'épidémies dans le pays et autres pays
très touché l'iran la france l'allemagne
et le royaume unis annoncent qu'ils vont
fournir au pays un soutien matériel et
financier
le recours aux 49 3 relance la
contestation sociale en france
l'intersyndicale s'est réunie ce matin
la cgt fo la cfe cgc fsu et solidaires
ainsi que les organisations de lycéens
et d'étudiants appellent à manifester
demain partout dans le pays
aujourd'hui plusieurs milliers de
personnes se sont mobilisées en france
comme ici à paris ou encore à lyon et
manifestants a dénoncé un passage en
force sur la réforme des retraites
écouter le député la france a soumises
moi je veux rappeler ce que nous avons
fait à l'assemblée nous n'avons rien
fait d'autre que d'importer au sein de
l'hémicycle
un mot d'ordre qui est majoritaire dans
le pays qui est l'exigence du retrait de
ce texte
ce projet de loi est illégitime puisque
il ne correspond absolument pas à la
promesse présidentielle d'instauration
d'un système universel il n'y a pas de
système universel
il n'y a pas un euro cotisé offrira les
mêmes droits il y a en l'occurrence une
vaste mesures d'âge qui va faire en
sorte que les français est un niveau de
pension qui va s'affaiblir parce qu'il
sera la seule variable d'ajustement de
l' équilibre financier qu'ils
recherchent donc avec les amendements
c'est ce que nous avons voulu faire je
montre qu'on entende bien que 41 mille
amendements sur un texte aussi important
que celui là c'est très loin d'être de
l'obstruction parlementaire
c'est un 49,3 des tournées et abusif
puisque le 49-3 normalement ne sert pas
à faire taire l'opposition parlementaire
le 49-3 sert à un exécutif qui craint
que sa majorité ne vote pas le texte
trop 49,3 très contestée on aura compris
jusque dans la majorité présidentielle
après le sénateur à la république en
marge des bouches-du-rhône michel amiel
c'est le député hubert julien laferrière
qui claque la porte du parti
tous deux dénoncent l' usage par le
gouvernement de cet article de la
constitution
l'opposition elle a déposé deux motions
censure contre le gouvernement elles
seront débattues demain à l'assemblée
nationale théo pompe avec guillemard
aussi
17h26 ce samedi edouard philippe
s'avance à la tribune devant les rangs
clairsemés de l'assemblée nationale à
l'issue d'une nouvelle suspension de
séance
il annonce alors ce que l'opposition
redoute depuis plusieurs jours
conformément à l'article 49 alinéa 3 de
la constitution de 1958 et après en
avoir obtenu l'autorisation du conseil
des ministres du 29 février
j'ai décidé d'engager la responsabilité
du gouvernement sur le projet de loi
instituant un système universel de
retraite non pour mettre fin au débat
mais pour mettre fin à cet épisode de
non débat à un parlement privé de sa
fonction éminente de faire la loi et
pour permettre à la suite du processus
législatif de s'engager
une déclaration qui prend les députés
par surprise y compris ceux de la
majorité
selon le quotidien le monde la plupart
des élus et les rues même qu'ils ne se
trouvent pas en séance apprennent la
nouvelle à la radio ou sur leur
smartphone alors que la tension monte
dans le pays en raison de l'épidémie de
coronavirus l'annnonce de l'exécutif a
fait l'effet d'une bombe
certains parlementaires appartenant au
parti présidentiel sont sidérés c'est
une incompréhensible erreur politique
stratégique et institutionnels
deux motions de censure ont été déposés
par l'opposition la première provient
des républicains l'autre est porté par
une alliance entre insoumis communistes
et socialistes d'émotion qui ont
toutefois très peu de chances d'aboutir
pour être validée et renverser le
gouvernement il faut obtenir une
majorité absolue au sein de l'assemblée
nationale située à 2 189 députés
or malgré les exclusions et autres
départs la majorité présidentielle
dispose toujours de 299 sièges auxquels
il faut rajouter
sauf surprise les 46 députés modem
depuis 1958 c'est la 89e fois qu'un
gouvernement engage sa responsabilité
via le 49-3 quant aux motions de censure
elles n'ont quasiment jamais abouti dans
toute l'histoire de la vème république
une seule a été adoptée par l'assemblée
c'était en 1962 contre le gouvernement
de georges pompidou il y a donc presque
60 ans
écoutez l'analyse de jean sébastien
ferjou fondateur d'atlantico directeur
de la publication
il ya un problème de calendrier et non
seulement il ya un point de calendrier
mais peut-être moins de maîtrise de la
part du gouvernement puisque si le
gouvernement en gros il ya les élections
municipales gouvernement souhaitait
avoir fini avant en tout cas la phase de
l'assemblée nationale avant
le premier tour des municipales ce qui
l'a contraint à s'engager dans une
procession une procédure accélérée et
c'est ce qui lui a fait qu'il ne peut
pas bénéficier de la procédure de temps
de temps programmé parlementaire donc le
gouvernement s'est lui même mis dans la
masse dans la nasse juridique on voit
bien que le sujet peut-être plus que
d'empêcher la reprise du mouvement c'est
d'empêcher ou de mettre un terme aux
débats qui commençait à se faire jour au
sein de sa propre majorité
s'il ya les élections municipales il ya
beaucoup de candidats qui sont enfin
deux candidats qui portent les couleurs
de la république en marche sur le
terrain qui se heurte à une forme
d'hostilité de la population et donc
c'est compliqué quand on est candidat
aux municipales à la fois de devoir
défendre nationalement le projet de loi
sur la réforme des retraites tout en se
montrant plus dubitatif dans les faits
pour éviter de suicide électoral
c'était hyper dogan se rendra en russie
jeudi il rencontrera son homologue russe
vladimir poutine pour évoquer l'escaladé
tension dans le nord ouest de la syrie
retour sur les derniers faits avec mehdi
eskers fille et florian lambert nouvelle
escalade militaire entre la turquie et
la syrie deux avions de combat syriens
étaient abattus ce dimanche par les
forces turques à idlib selon l'agencé de
presse sana
la turquie qui assure vouloir éviter
toute confrontation avec la russie
annonce la poursuite de son offensive
dans la région baptisée bouclier de
printemps cette opération déclenchée fin
février a été qualifiée de succès par
ankara vendredi celle syriens ont été
tués par des bombardements de
représailles menées par l'armée turque
dans le nord ouest du pays
de leur côté la russie et l'otan appelle
au respect des accords de cessez le feu
signé à sotchi en 2018
le problème chez nous c'est qu'il faut
commencer à
respecter les engagements pris et
pendant un an et demi nous avons
constaté que pas grand chose n'a été
fait et que l'armée syrienne a tout à
fait le droit de d'éliminer les
terroristes et nous demandons de manière
urgente un retour à l'accord de
cessez-le-feu de 2018 pour éviter que la
situation militaire non pire encore dans
la région et pour autoriser
l'intervention urgente de l'aide
humanitaire pour les personnes bloquées
adlib le conflit à esbly bas aussi de
lourdes conséquences sur le plan
humanitaire selon l'onu
les affrontements déjà fait des
centaines de milliers de déplacés
des dizaines de milliers de personnes
vivent maintenant dans des abris de
fortune dans des bâtiments publics en
plein air de loterie sous les arbres
exposés à la pluie à la neige dans le
froid glacial du rigoureux hiver syriens
pour tenter de trouver une issue à la
crise le président français a pas de la
turquie et la russie à établir un cessez
le feu durable dans la région d'idlib
ces feux que recep tayyip erdogan espère
trouver rapidement de son côté le
kremlin a affirmé que la coopération
avec ankara était d'une grande
importance
une rencontre entre vladimir poutine et
le chef d'état turc doit avoir lieu ce
jeudi à moscou pour en discuter
enfin conséquence de la situation en
syrie la grèce est confrontée à un
afflux de migrants depuis que la turquie
a ouvert sa frontière pour faire
pression sur les occidentaux agence
européenne de contrôle des frontières
ontex devrait rapidement lancé une
opération de soutien au pays guilhem
herbert revient sur la situation
drapeau blanc à la main ces migrants la
frontière gréco-turque demande la paix
bloquées dans un no man's land entre les
deux pays il espérait rentrer en europe
mais ont trouvé une frontière fermée à
double tour
plus tôt dans la matinée le gouvernement
grec diffuser des vidéos de heurts à la
frontière avec la turquie pour recep
tayyip erdogan
l'europe doit prendre sa part du fardeau
depuis le moment où nous avons ouvert
nos frontières le nombre de ceux qui se
sont dirigés vers l'europe a atteint les
centaines de milliers et il y en aura
plus bientôt ce nombre s'exprimera en
millions une menace directe pour l'union
européenne qui enverra dès demain des
représentants sur place demain les
représentants des trois institutions
européennes le parlement le conseil et
la commission c'est à dire le président
david sassoli le président charles
michel et moi même nous rendons semble
en grèce pour témoigner du plein soutien
de l'union européenne comme je les dis
le défi auquel la grèce est confrontée
est un défi européen et la grèce à notre
total soutien
un déplacement pour tenter d'endiguer
cette crise qui laisse des milliers de
migrants sans solution de son côté
angela merkel jugent inacceptable qu
ankara fasse pression sur l'union
européenne sur le dos des réfugiés et
pour catherine chaque dame spécialiste
du moyen-orient ces pourparlers ont tout
l'air d'être la rencontre de la dernière
chance pour la série je pense que les
deux présidents ne sont pas très amis
pas sur le plan politique
quant à la vision qu'ils ont pour le
moyen-orient voyant ils ont des visions
très différentes
je pense que la russie par la
collaboration avec les gouvernements
en bref il sait aussi apprécier ou pas
certaines politiques
à la question de ces la la coloration de
la turquie avec toutes les troupes qui
attriste et sa vision des questions
religieuses et comment comment gérer ces
questions moyen-orientaux que je pense
que cela va être très difficile d'avoir
100 souvent en désaccord et benyamin
nétanyahou revendique la victoire aux
élections législatives selon des
sondages en sorties d'urne le leader du
likoud récolte aurait entre 36 et 37
sièges à la knesset et devancerait ainsi
son rival du parti bleu et blanc benny
ganz ce dernier n'obtiendraient qu'entre
32 et 33 sièges le premier ministre
sortant obtiendrait au moins quatre
sièges de plus par rapport aux
législatives de septembre dernier et
paraît en meilleure position pour former
un gouvernement les palestiniens déplore
une victoire des partisans de l'annexion
des directions présent les états unis où
pete beauty djedj jeté l'épongé dans la
course à la primaire démocrate
les médias annoncent également que la
sénatrice claude bouchard allait se
retirer et soutenir joe biden en
caroline du sud l'ancien vice-président
distancé de près de 30 points le
sénateur du vermont bernie sanders ont
fait le point avec grégoire dont ces
séries albouy la primaire démocrate est
relancé
joe biden en tête et avec une avance
confortable
après un départ au ralenti dans les
états précédent l'ex bras droit de
barack obama est de retour devant ses
partisans
il n'a pas attendu pour se réjouir de sa
première place en caroline du sud où il
a récolté près de 49% des suffrages
[Applaudissements]
il y a quelques jours à peine la presse
et les experts estimé que cette
candidature était morte
maintenant grâce à vous tous le coeur du
parti démocrate
nous venons de remporter une victoire
est une grande victoire grâce à vous
déception en revanche pour celui qui a
connu un démarrage en trombe lors de
cette primaire bernie sanders le
candidat de l'ailé gauche du parti a
récolté seulement 20% des voix
mais ce lot optimiste pour la suite nous
entrons dans le super tuesday en
virginie et je crois très fermement que
les gens de ce pays pour le super
tuesday et après vont soutenir notre
campagne parce que nous sommes plus
qu'une campagne
nous sommes un mouvement
et c'est dimanche soir que la outsiders
pitbull judge a annoncé son retrait de
la course à l'investiture présidentielle
rappelant que son objectif est de
rassembler les américains face à donald
trump
je prends la décision de suspendre ma
campagne pour la présidentielle
je ne chercherait plus à être candidat
démocrate à la présidence pour 2020 mais
je ferai tout ce qui est en leur pouvoir
pour que nous allions au nouveau
président démocrate en janvier
une annonce surprise qui n'a pas tardé à
faire réagir le président américain bill
bennett james est out
tous ces votes pour le super tuesday
iront à joe biden l'endormi excellent
timing c'est le vrai début de
l'élimination de bernis par les
démocrates
encore une fois pas de nominations
toutefois pas de répit pour les
candidats démocrates toujours en lice
avant le super tuesday qui arrive dès
demain mardi 3 mars
un événement qui constituera forcément
un tournant dans la primaire démocrate
avec 14 et a appelé à se prononcer cette
annonce de pete beach head qui
intervient donc juste avant le fameux
super tuesday ce sera demain 14 états
qui vont voter en même temps une date
cruciale pour tous les candidats à la
primaire démocrate
[Musique]
et c'est la fin de ce journal merci
d'avoir suivi prochain point sur l'actu
demain matin 7 heures du matin heure
française excellente fin de soirée à
tous eu r
[Musique]
nous allons évoquer ici des sujets
stratégiques pour notre pays et sur ces
dossiers sensibles
je vais partager avec vous mon
interprétation quelle que soit la
qualité expertise indéniable nos soldats
ils ne peuvent gagner la guerre pour la
raison que je vais maintenant qu'on peut
faire un peu plus de 5000 militaires
français à l'efficacité certes reconnu
sur une zone aussi vaste même renforcé
par cinq mille soldats promis par les
pays vieux saint calais c'est là où les
problèmes ont commencé
les déclarations récentes des politiques
des spécialistes des experts des
militaires montre bien que nous sommes
face à une incompréhension totale entre
les différents acteurs
si la france n'a pas la volonté
nécessaire pour assurer la réalisation
de ses objectifs et de les accompagner
par qu'il ne s'agit pas d'imposer il
s'agit de convaincre et d'accompagner il
est à craindre que nous terminions
enlisé dans un conflit sans fin
[Musique]
l'huile de palme est l'un des produits
les plus controversées de notre temps
c'est une graisse végétale solide et
elle est très bon marché en 2010 est la
production a atteint un sommet de 63
millions de tonnes cette croissance
rapide de la demande globale d'huile peu
coûteuse à cause d une expansion massive
des plantations de palmiers à huile
ce qui entraîne à son tour la
destruction de la forêt tropicale
[Musique]
dans la seule indonésie plus de dix
millions d'hectares de forêts primaires
ont été détruits et cela se poursuit
[Musique]
ah bon des femmes bon et maintenant les
femmes ce qui a été l'histoire jusqu'à
maintenant était biaisé
[Musique]